Shon, happy holidays to you, if you're a musical genius, if you were to make up a new Christmas classic song, how would it go? What if I give you a little beat right now, you write some lyrics, right? So, Merry Christmas to Jason and Will. Merry Christmas, Merry Christmas. Do you know anybody named Bill? Merry Christmas. Merry Christmas.
肖恩，祝你节日快乐。如果你是个音乐天才，如果要你创作一首新的圣诞经典歌曲，你会怎么写？如果我现在给你一段节奏，你来写几句歌词怎么样？祝杰森和威尔圣诞快乐。圣诞快乐，圣诞快乐。你认识叫比尔的人吗？圣诞快乐。圣诞快乐。
This is going to give kids nightmares. What's going on? Welcome to Smart List. Welcome to Smart List. Welcome to Smart List. Enjoy the show. It's going to be better than the song. We're just talking about dirty desktops, Shon, and dirty inboxes.
这会给孩子们留下心理阴影的。怎么回事？欢迎来到《聪明清单》。欢迎来到《聪明清单》。欢迎来到《聪明清单》。享受节目吧。它会比那首歌更好听。肖恩，我们刚才在聊凌乱的桌面和凌乱的收件箱。
Do you have like a bunch of emails that you have? You haven't read, or you did read, and you haven't really deleted them, and it's not in sync with your iPhone, and are you a mess technologically, or is it tight? So funny. Answer the question. Answer the question, Shon. Or take your time. We're not on the air or anything.
你是不是有一堆邮件没读，或者读了但没删，而且还没跟你的iPhone同步？你在技术上是个乱七八糟的人，还是井井有条？太搞笑了。回答问题。回答问题，肖恩。或者慢慢来。我们又没在直播。
You know what? I don't delete emails, but I don't go back and check them out. Is that the question? No. How many do you keep unread, I think, is what he's getting? Oh, no. I like zero, zero, zero unread. So once you read them, you don't delete them?
你知道吗？我不删邮件，但我也不回去查看它们。这是问题吗？不是。我想他问的是你留了多少未读邮件？哦，不。我喜欢零，零，零未读。所以一旦读了，你就不删它们？
Why not? No. Well, I don't know. It's an extra step. I didn't think I had to do. So you just have all the emails you've ever received are sitting in your inbox. So your inbox is empty? No.
为什么不删？不。嗯，我不知道。那是多余的一步。我觉得没必要做。所以你收到的所有邮件都堆在收件箱里。那你的收件箱是空的吗？不。
It's full. No. All my emails I've ever received. Yours I'm saying to Jason. Yeah. Absolutely clean. The only emails that I have read that I keep in there are the things that I need to respond to when I have the time to really focus on them and respond to them.
它是满的。不。我收到的所有邮件都在那儿。我是说给杰森听的。是的。绝对干净。我保留的已读邮件只有那些我需要时间专注处理并回复的。
They're like a little reminder, like to-do list. You keep them unread, right? No, no, no. I read them. And then if they're in the inbox still, that means I still have yet to respond to them. So what you can do is, alternatively, you can keep them read, but you still hold onto them in case you need to reference them and go like, hey, what was that thing I need to go back?
它们就像小提醒，像待办事项列表。你把它们留作未读，对吧？不，不，不。我读了它们。如果它们还在收件箱里，意味着我还没回复。所以你可以换种做法，你可以把它们标记为已读，但保留着，以防你需要参考，比如“嘿，我需要回去看的那件事是什么？”
Because I go back all the time. But that's in the trash. You can just go into the trash and see them there. No, because they eventually get deleted. So like, I need- You have a thing you can check and say never delete. Guys, guys. I'll be like, you know, did I get that version of the script or like, especially if I'm going
因为我总是回去查看。但那在垃圾箱里。你可以直接去垃圾箱看。不，因为它们最终会被删除。所以我需要——你有个选项可以勾选“永不删除”。伙计们，伙计们。我会想，你知道，我收到那个版本的剧本了吗？或者，特别是如果我正在和查皮（Chappie）来回修改草稿，我会想，哦，等等，该死的草稿在哪儿？哦，查皮。天哪，肖恩，我就知道我们会提到查皮。是的，查皮。今天很早啊。你好，老查皮。马克·查佩尔，英国历史上最伟大的作家。
back and forth that I'm doing drafts with Chappie, I'll be like, oh, wait, where was the fucking drafts? Oh, Chappie. Boy, Sean, I knew we'd get a Chappie. Yeah, Chappie. It's early today. Hello, old Chappie. Mark Chappell, the greatest writer in the history of Britain.
就是这样。这就是那句名言。这就是那个片段。你们——等等，你——我刚才要说什么关于——你知道，我遇到的问题，我希望苹果公司能听到，问题出在iMessage上。当我读了某人的短信，心想“哦，我真的很想回复，但我现在没时间像它应得的那样专注处理”，我想把它标记为未读，这样它就会保持高亮，否则我会忘了回去处理。然后对方就会觉得我是个混蛋，而我其实在努力假装自己不是。抱歉，肖恩在和旁边的人说话。怎么了？它跑了。是的，看得出来吗？你们房间里也有像我们这样转来转去的灯吗？
There we go. There is the quote. That's the clip. Did you guys- Wait, do you- but do you- what was I going to say about- You know, the problem I have, and I hope Apple's listening, the problem is on iMessage. When I read a text from somebody and I go, oh, I really want to respond to that, but I don't have the time to really focus on it the way that it deserves, I want to mark
你知道我们在录音，对吧？抱歉，斯科蒂刚才问我什么。等等。我们喜欢这样。什么？不，但是——是关于鲜奶油吗？他问我茶里要不要再加一份糖。
it as unread so that it stays lit up, because otherwise I'll forget to go back to it. And then the person thinks I'm just the A-hole that I'm trying to pretend not to be when I don't respond. Sorry, Sean's having a conversation with somebody on the side. What's going on? It's got away. Yeah, can you tell? Do you guys have a night's spinning around in your room like we do?
他真的问了吗？是的。等等，你在喝茶？哦，对了。你不喝咖啡，对吧，肖恩？不，我喝茶，但它像奶昔一样，因为我加了大量的奶油和糖。太令人震惊了。但等等，关于这个的最后一点，因为我想，你知道现在，杰森，你可以从手机上撤回发送了。
You know we're rolling, right? Sorry, Scottie was asking me something. Wait. We love that. What? No, but- Is it about whipped cream? He asked me if I wanted another sugar in my tea.
那是最新的iPhone更新。等等，短信吗？所以如果你发了封邮件，你可以——哦，对。是的。有个“哎呀”按钮。是的，比如如果你想编辑它。
Did he really? Yeah. Wait, you have tea? Oh, that's right. You don't drink coffee, do you, Sean? No, I drink tea, but it's like a milkshake, because I put tons of cream and sugar in it. That's shocking. But wait, the last thing about that, because I think, you know now, Jason, you can unsend
那怎么运作？它是从发送者的收件箱消失，还是从接收者的收件箱消失？哦，真的吗？没错。嗯，我还是觉得如果能把短信标记为未读会很方便，但他们还没做。我今天为此很火大。威尔，我看到你又穿白色的了，肖恩，我看到你又戴帽子了。
from your phone. That's the latest iPhone update. Wait, on text? So if you send an email, you have, you can- Oh, right. Yeah. There's an oops, there's an oops button. Yeah, like if you wanted to edit it.
是的。我不总是穿白色。是的，你穿。这让你的牙齿看起来很显眼。你在说什么？好了。我们继续吧。现在是清晨，我的朋友们话不多，所以我们要——我们要介绍——不，我可以聊聊。我非常健谈，但是——我可以聊聊。是的，我确实想介绍你的嘉宾，但你知道——你有什么值得聊的吗？肖恩，看你的清单。好吧，让我想想。
How does that work? Does it then disappear from the sender's inbox or from the recipients? Oh, really? That's correct. Well, I still think that it would be easy for them to mark texts as unread, if you'd like to, but they haven't done it yet. I'm pissed about it today. Will, I see you're white again, Sean, I see you have a hat on again.
你做过什么工作？你今天有什么话题？嗯，我有——哦，第一个话题是，哦，如果他开始读，斯科蒂过来问我关于它的事？不，阿蒂做了那个。不。嗯，还记得我们请瑞安·约翰逊来的时候，斯科蒂只要有任何关于《星球大战》的引用，他就会出现。
Yeah. I don't always wear white. Yeah, you do. Makes your teeth pop. What are you talking about? All right. Let's get on with it. It's early in the morning and my friends aren't that chatty, so we're going to go ahead and
尤恩来的时候，他也亮过相。好了，我们今天有位嘉宾。好的。他不得不忍受很多废话。嗯，大概吧。所以我们今天有位嘉宾，他以某种方式设法保持低调，并在许多领域做了一些非常酷的工作，很多人都注意到了并受到了影响。其中一些是表演，一些是导演，一些是制片，一些是——
we're going to introduce- No, I can chat about stuff. I am very chatty, but- I can chat about stuff. Yeah, and I do want to get to your guests, but you know what it is- Do you have anything worth chatting about? Sean, go to your list. Okay, let me just think.
创业、慈善、环保。你刚才说慈善吗？是的，他说了。好的。慈善。好了。他一直都在我们身边，但我们对他知之甚少，或者至少比你根据他的名气所预期的要少。嗯，今天这个硬核调查新闻节目将结束这一切。他出生在波士顿。他娶了一位加拿大人。竖起耳朵，威尔。是的。
What have you worked on? What are your bits today? Well, I have- Oh, the first bit was, oh, what if he started reading, Scotty coming to ask me about it? No, Artie did that. No. Well, remember when we had Ryan Johnson on and Scotty just, Scotty appears whenever there's a Star Wars reference of any kind.
他会说日语。什么？从看《灰姑娘》开始有了表演瘾。他在《飞燕金枪》中首次亮相，竖起耳朵，肖恩，有一个孩子，三次奥斯卡提名，耶鲁大学学位，懂合气道和以色列格斗术，还是莫莉和詹姆斯的哥哥。各位，请欢迎肖恩的朋友，爱德华·哈里森·诺顿。不会吧。哦，看看这家伙。
When Ewan was on, he made a bright appearance as well. All right, we got a fella today. Okay. Who has had to put up with a lot of BS? Well, probably. So we got a fella today that has somehow managed to keep his head down and do some really cool work in a lot of different areas that many people notice and are affected by. Some of that is acting, some of that is directing, some of that is producing, some of that is
我的天哪。是的。今天真是高水准。是的。你提升了档次。经典嘉宾。很高兴见到你。他就在那儿。
entrepreneurial, philanthropic, environmental. Did you just say philanthropic? Yeah, he did. Okay. Philanthropic. All right. He's been all, I'm going to start at the top. Don't you dare.
哇。我喜欢这个灯光。我需要一条毛巾咬着。我在热身时咬穿了我的拇指。因为太尴尬了。是的，因为太尴尬了。因为我们这种凯利和瑞吉斯的氛围，对吧？我想我们都只是——只是太早了。
Don't you dare. He's been all around us, but we know very little about him or at least less than you would assume given his fame. Well, that ends today with this hard-hitting investigative journalistic hour. He was born in Boston. He's married to a Canadian. Prick up, Will. Yeah.
我们累了。我们有点累。我知道。太可爱了。让我们问他一些硬核的新闻问题。你刚才读的内容里有太多奇怪的东西了。比如，你在哪儿，你在看什么？除了维基百科之外的东西。
He speaks Japanese. What? Got the acting bug from watching Cinderella. He debuted in Annie, Get Your Gun, Prick Up, Sean, has one kid, three Oscar nominations, a degree from Yale, knows Akito and Krav Maga, and he's big brother to Molly and James. Folks, please welcome Sean's dude, Edward Harrison Norton. No way. Oh, look at this guy.
我不知道。就是直接从维基百科看的。全是维基百科。你是编造那些东西吗，比如以色列格斗术？他会把一些有趣的东西编进维基百科里。嗯，我通常，是的，我通常会加一些不真实的东西。但这——我没加任何东西。合气道和以色列格斗术确实在你的页面上。
Oh my God. Yeah. Big slice of class today. Yeah. You classed it up. Classic guest. So nice to meet you. There he is.
那不准确吗？不。我得去和吉米·威尔斯谈谈以色列格斗术的事。我想你的车现在正被偷。我在偷你的车。还是那是肖恩？那不是我。那是斯科蒂趁肖恩分心时溜走了。
Wow. I like the lighting. I needed a towel to bite on. I bit through my thumb during the warm-up. Because it was so embarrassing. Yeah, because it was so embarrassing. Because of the Kelly and Regis vibe to our powder, right? I think we're all just, it's just early.
我不知道。不，那不是我。所以你，等等，但你确实懂日语？是的，我还可以。哇。那真的很棒。什么叫“还可以”？那是我年轻时充满热情做的事情之一，然后我去了那里生活。你知道，我还可以。我还可以。我能做些足以给人留下深刻印象的事，比如在东京的发布会上，我可以让他们感到兴奋，然后在我说完那些听起来很高级的关键短语后，我就什么都听不懂了。你能说“天哪，有人在偷我的车”吗？不，我就是这个意思。
We're tired. We're a little tired. I know. It's too cute. Let's give him some hard-hitting journalistic questions. There was so much weird stuff in what you just read. Like, where do you, what are you on? Like, something other than Wikipedia that's doing it.
真的吗？不。但你确实学习过，然后你去那里工作了几年。但这已经是很久以前的事了。我们现在都中年了。是的。我不记得了。我们所有人。
I don't know. It's just straight Wikipedia. That's all Wikipedia. Were you making that stuff up, like, Krav Maga? He kind of weaves in his little funny is that he weaves stuff into Wikipedia. Well, I usually, yeah, I usually add some stuff that's not true. But this is, I didn't do any ads. Akido and Krav Maga is on your page.
现在都过了中年了。但我们都在三十多岁时扮演过角色。我们确实做过。这太神奇了。爱德华，我们在哪儿找到你？你现在在东海岸吗？不，我在加利福尼亚。加利福尼亚。
Is that not accurate? No. I'm going to have to go talk with Jimmy Wells and Krav Maga. I think your car is getting stolen right now. I was stealing your car. Or is that Sean? That's not me. That's Scottie making a run for it while Sean is distracted.
哇。等等，所以你娶了一位加拿大人？是的。肖娜·罗伯逊。我不知道她，我只见过她几次。我想我们从未见过面。正式认识一下。是的。
I don't know. No, that's not me. So you, but hang on, but you do know Japanese? Yeah, I'm okay on that. Wow. That's real good. What do you mean they're okay on that? I was like one of those things I did in my youth with a lot of passion and then I went
彼此彼此。我不知道肖娜是加拿大人。她是哪儿人？多伦多。多伦多郊外的加拿大农场女孩。别开玩笑了。父母还在那儿的一个100英亩的农场里。安大略省的哪个部分，你能说出那个地区吗？
and lived over there. You know, I'm okay. I'm okay. I can do enough to impress, like, in the junket in Tokyo, I can get them all flutter and then I don't understand anything they're saying after I've done my few key phrases that sound sophisticated. Can you say, good God, somebody's stealing my car? No, that's what I mean.
马克姆。马克姆。当然，是的。是的。马克姆。哦，那是加拿大人吗？是的。但她来了，她，你知道，她几乎在18岁时就开始制作电影了。
Really? No. But you did study it and then you went there and you worked for a few years. But this has been a long time. We're all like middle aged now. Yeah. I can't remember. All of us.
是的。那是真的。为迈克·宾德。不。哦，当然。迈克·宾德，我们的朋友，节目的朋友。对。
Well past middle aged now. But we all play, we all play roles in our thirties. We sure do. That's what's amazing. Edwin, where are we finding you? Are you on the East Coast right now? No, I'm in California. California.
是的。我们认识迈克·宾德。你肯定认识。真有趣。我真的，我坐在这儿想，我其实很惊讶我们没见过面。我觉得。是的。我也很惊讶。
Wow. And wait, and so you're married to a Canadian? Yeah. Shana Robertson. I didn't know that she, I've only met her a handful of times. I don't think we've ever met. Nice to meet you formally. Yeah.
我很惊讶你不认识肖娜。是的。我见过肖娜好几次，过去20年里大概四五次。是的。只是简短地，她曾经为贾德工作过吗？是的。嗯，她和贾德创办了Apatow。她制作了贾德所有的电影。
Likewise. I didn't know that Shana was Canadian. Where is she from? Toronto. Canadian farm girl from outside Toronto. No kidding. Parents are still on a 100 acre farm out there. What part of, Ontario, can you say the area?
对。哦，真的吗？所以我猜就是那样。那很酷。然后。她制作了《精灵》。她制作了《精灵》，她制作了《王牌播音员》，然后她和贾德在《王牌播音员》之后合作，然后做了《四十岁的老处男》和《一夜大肚》那一整套。
Markham. Markham. Of course, yeah. Yeah. Markham. Oh, is that Canadian? Yeah. But she came, she, you know, she started producing movies when she was literally like 18 years
对。她制作过你参与的作品吗？你们是怎么认识的？不。不。只是，我们在伦敦认识的。什么？
old. Yeah. That's true. For Mike Binder. No. Oh, of course. Mike Binder, friend of ours, friend of the show. Right.
伍迪·哈里森和他的妻子介绍我们认识的。嗯，那怎么样？我们去了，伍迪当时在西区演《鬣蜥之夜》。太棒了。其实当时非常，我正在纽约排练一部电影，我对这个过程有点恼火，他们问我：“明天能再来一天吗？”我当时有一种非常冲动、有点被动攻击的行为。我说：“不，不，我明天没空。”
Yeah. We know Mike Binder. Sure would you. It's funny. I'm really, I'm sitting here thinking, I'm actually surprised that we haven't met. Like I feel like. Yeah. I'm surprised too.
他们说：“你知道，为什么？”我说：“哦，我今晚要去伦敦看朋友演戏。”我当时有那个计划。很快买了张票。所以我得去。然后我打电话，我真的上了，你知道。Expedia。是的，Expedia，买了张去伦敦的票，给伍迪打电话说：“我要去看你。”
I'm surprised you don't know Shana. Yeah. I've met Shana a number of times, probably four or five times over the last 20 years. Yeah. Just briefly, did she work for Judd at one point? Yeah. Well, she and Judd started Apatow. She produced all Judd's movies.
然后，你知道，就是那样。然后它改变了你的人生。是的。所以这太疯狂了。我们注定要相遇。现在你有阿特拉斯了，你正驶向夕阳，扮演父亲的角色。现在。所以。
Right. Oh, really? So I suppose that was it. That's cool. And then. She did Elf. She did Elf and she produced Elf and she produced Anchorman, Anchorman and then she and Judd teamed up after Anchorman and then did that whole run of 40-year-old Virgin and knocked
等等，杰森，你和爱德华认识吗？我们认识。我们有点了解。比如怎么认识的？从哪儿？我不知道。嗯，通过肖娜。肖娜。
out. Right. Did she produce something that you were working on? Is that how you guys met? No. No. Just, we met in London. What?
加克斯。是的。是的。小聚会。是的。还有，阿曼达。你是肖恩和阿曼达的朋友。是的。
Woody Harrelson and his wife introduced us. Well, how about that? We went, Woody was doing, Woody was doing Night of the Iguana on the West End. Amazing. And actually it was very, I was rehearsing a movie in New York and I was getting a little aggravated with the process and they were like, can you do another day tomorrow? And I had this very impulsive, it was a little bit of a passive-aggressive thing. I said, no, no, I can't, I'm not free tomorrow.
阿曼达。阿曼达是我整个社交生活的关键。正如你们俩所知。那肯定是。威尔和肖恩。是的。你知道，我，我，我谁也不认识。我没有朋友。
And they said, you know, how come? And I said, oh, I'm going to London tonight to see a friend in a play. And I had that plan. Quickly bought a ticket. So I got to go. And then I called, I literally went on like, you know. Expedia. Yeah, Expedia and got a ticket to London and called Woody and said, I'm coming to see you
杰森，我必须说，我总是对你了解别人孩子名字的程度感到惊讶，甚至有点震惊。你总是叫出他们的名字，就像，你知道，我做了一点研究，你知道，但你那种轻松抛出的方式让我觉得我真的很熟悉他们的名字。事实上，我只是在研究我的笔记。发生的情况是，这对嘉宾来说是卸下防备的，因为他们会想，哦，天哪。
and, and that's, you know, that's, that's. And then it changed your life. Yeah. So that's crazy. We was meant to, meant to be. And now you got Atlas and you're just sailing off into the sunset, playing dad. Now. So.
我意识到这是一种风格，我对此表示怀疑。对。他们以为我在乎，以为我和他们很亲近，其实全是，我是一个职业骗子。我们都是。但我们现在就揭穿他吧。因为他在维基百科上，他其实还以为我只有一个孩子。我其实有两个，因为维基百科上写错了。
Wait, Jason, do you and Ed know each other? We do. We know a little bit. Like how? From, from where? I don't know. Well, through Shawna. Shawna.
所以他刚才，顺便说一句，你知道，他会杀了阿曼达。让我说完。告诉我，告诉我小塞巴斯蒂安怎么样了，他还是个小天使吗？杰森，阿曼达会因为这个杀了你的。该死，会因为那个杀了我。她会杀了你的。而且你知道吗？让我告诉你一件事。
Gax. Yeah. Yeah. Little mixers. Yeah. And, and Amanda. You're Sean and Amanda friends. Yeah.
这是，天哪，你刚才揭穿了我，爱德华。所以事情是这样的。我大约一小时前在做我的小笔记，我看到维基百科上，是的。所以阿特拉斯，我想，天哪，你知道，阿曼达昨天给我发了两张照片。看起来像两个不同的孩子。但后来我想，嗯，不，维基百科上只有阿特拉斯。那一定是阿特拉斯的一张旧照片。天哪。
Amanda. Amanda is the key to my entire social life. As you two guys know. That is for sure. Will and Sean. Yeah. You know, I, I, I know no one. I have no friends.
因为我，我想，该死。所以现在阿曼达会说：“嘿，混蛋，我给你发了两张照片，两个孩子。”他会说：“再一次，你相信维基百科胜过她。”再一次，这证明了一件事，永远相信我的直觉。我很高兴我们深入挖掘了这一点，因为这里有太多的收获。好了。但在我辩护时，他们都有漂亮的长而奢华的金发，对吧？
Jason, I must say, I'm always amazed slash slightly shocked at how, how well you know other people's kids names. You always call out their names like, you know, I do a little research, you know, but the way that you throw it out with, with such ease makes it seem like I'm really familiar with their name. And in fact, I've just been studying my notes. And what happens is, and it's disarming for the, for the, for the guests because they go, oh man.
这可能是男孩也可能是女孩，因为他们有这些很棒的轮廓分明的特征。一个是男孩，一个是女孩。他们九岁和六岁，但他们都。他有，他有真正的，像格雷格·奥尔曼那种水平的，你知道，很多是接发，对吧？我，有些人说，天哪，他看起来像，你知道，《燃情岁月》里的布拉德·皮特。我当时想，我觉得更像雪儿时代的格雷格·奥尔曼，你知道，所以——
And I realize it's a style and I call BS on it. Right. They think that I care and that I'm close with them and it's all, it's all, I'm a professional liar. We all are. Let's, let's, let's bust him right now though. But because he's on Wikipedia, he actually thinks I only have one child still. And I actually have two because they have that wrong on Wikipedia.
等等，杰森，说到孩子，我想看看这是否是一个都市传说，因为它在我们家已经成了经常被重复的故事，当谈到工作与家庭的动态时，其中一个女孩听到你告诉阿曼达《黑钱胜地》要续订第二季，她凑过去说：“哦，我真的很期待能更好地了解你。”这是真的吗？不，我需要知道这是不是真的。你的一个女儿对你说：“我真的很期待能更好地了解你”吗？
And so he just, by the way, you know, he's going to kill Amanda. Let me finish. Tell me, tell me how little Sebastian is doing, is he still a little angel? Jason, Amanda is going to kill you for this. Fucking kill me for that. She is going to kill you. And you know, and you know what else? Let me tell you something.
这是我第一次听到这个该死的故事。但我并不怀疑它是真的。把那个传给我们。嗯，你看，阿曼达可能在保护我，而你，爱德华，现在伤害了我。不，那太搞笑了。我被谋杀了。这是最伟大的事情之一。听起来像是六岁时的弗兰妮。
Here's a, God, you just busted me, Edward. So here's the thing. So I was doing my little notes about an hour ago and, and I see on Wikipedia, yeah. So Atlas, I'm like, boy, you know, Amanda sent me two pictures yesterday. It looked like two different kids. But then I thought, then I thought, well, no, Wikipedia's just got Atlas there. That must be a second picture of an older picture of Atlas. Boy.
时间点差不多。现在的《聪明清单》是四个人吗？这就是现在的样子吗？爱德华是常驻嘉宾吗？这太不可思议了。如果有人生病或类似情况，我们很乐意让你留在替补席上。我可以做披头士乐队的第四个披头士。你们其他人都会穿浅色，我会穿红色的保罗。肖恩，你知道披头士只有三个，然后他们引进了第四个吗？
Because I, and I'm like, God damn it. So now Amanda's going to be like, hey, Dick, I sent you two pictures, two children. And he's going to say, once again, you trusted Wikipedia over her. And once again, it's proven one thing, always trust my instincts. I was so right. I'm so glad that we dug into this because there was so much fruit here. All right. But in my defense, they both have beautifully long, luxurious blonde hair, right?
不对。这是你在说话，是的，那个笑的家伙是个笨蛋，他很惊讶地听到披头士（Beatles）拼写是B-E-A-T，他当时想，哈，嘿，那很聪明。嘿，听着，阴茎。有很多评论。我们还在叫他阴茎吗？我叫他阴茎。有很多评论同意我的观点。
Which could be boy or girl because they're, they've got these great sharp features. One's a boy, one's a girl. And they're nine and six, but they, they did both. He had, he had real, like Greg Allman level, you know, a lot of that was extension, so right? I, some people were saying, God, he looks like, you know, Brad Pitt and legends of the fall. And I was like, I think it's a little more Greg Allman, like share era, you know, so
他们也不知道。嗯，他们和你一样笨。那是真的。是的，肖恩就像，哦，那就像汤姆·汉克斯的电影《那东西你做》，你知道，他的电影是关于那个热门单曲的，你知道，那个，哦，任何，他用汤姆·汉克斯的导演处女作来引用披头士，就像《那东西你做》，《那东西你做》，《那东西你做》。
wait, Jason, speaking of kids, I want to see if this is an urban legend because it's become an oft repeated story in our family when it comes to work family dynamics that one of the girls heard you over telling Amanda that Ozark was going to get picked up for season two and that she leaned in and said, oh, I was really looking forward to getting to know you better. Is that true? No, I need to know if it's true. Did one of your girls say to you, I was really looking forward to getting to know you better.
说到处女作，所以爱德华，我不知道在哪儿，你在国家的哪个部分长大？哥伦比亚。我有那部分。我有那部分。中部。他出生在马萨诸塞州的波士顿，然后他在马里兰州长大。在马里兰州。
That's the first time I've fucking heard that. But I don't doubt that it's true. And pass that one along to us. Well, you see, Amanda was probably protecting me and you, Edward, have now scarred me. No, that's so funny. I am murdered. This is one of the greatest things. It sounds like Franny at about age six.
哦，哇。巴尔的摩，华盛顿。你在芝加哥待过吗？我以为没有。好了。不。没关系。你，所以你长大时，艺术是你生活中很重要的一部分吗？
Which times out about right. Is smartlist now four people? Is this what it is now? Is Edward a permanent, this is so phenomenal. We would love to keep you in the bullpen in the event of illness or anything like that. I could be the fourth beetle on the leaded beetle. The rest of you will all be in light and I'll be Paul in red. Sean, did you know that there was only three beetles and then they brought in the fourth?
你做过什么吗？你，你多大时开始表演或演戏或什么的？是的。我的意思是，答案是肯定的。我，我的父母不是艺术家，但他们是戏剧爱好者。他们热爱戏剧。他们热爱电影。我很高兴你说了“爱好者”。
Not true. This is you talking, yeah, the guy laughing is the dumb ass that was surprised to hear that beetles is spelled B-E-A-T and he was like, huh, hey, that is clever. Hey, listen, penis. There's a ton of comments. Are we still calling him penis? I called him penis. There's a ton of comments that agree with me.
这是一个我会用的词，它会把这两个该死的白痴都搞糊涂，但谢谢你。是的，昨天，他抛出了几个多音节词，简直是。我说了，肖恩眯起眼睛更多了。不。我知道为什么。你会大声说，我有时会记录每个人说的有趣的事情。
They didn't know either. Well, they're dumb as you. That's true. Yeah. Sean's like, oh, that's like in the Tom Hanks movie, The Wonders, you know, what was his movie about the one hit, you know, the one, oh, any, he uses a Tom Hanks directorial debut to reference the beetles like that thing you do, that thing you do, that thing you do.
当你讲你那个非常好的故事时，我开始笑杰森说：“嗯，他们和你一样笨。”是的。所以他也有延迟，爱德华。我有点延迟。突触有点生锈了。现在是赞助商时间。《聪明清单》由GMC支持。
Speaking of debuts, so Edward, I don't know where, where did, what part of the country did you grow up in? Columbia. I've got that part. I've got that part. Central. He was born in Boston, Massachusetts, and then he was brought up in Maryland. In Maryland.
当GMC发布全电动Sierra EV Denali Edition 1时，人们有疑问，比如电动皮卡怎么能提供那么大的马力，或者是什么让Ultium电池技术如此创新？或者甚至当你折叠Sierra首创的创新Multi-Pro中门时，它去哪儿了？但到目前为止，关于第一款电动Sierra皮卡我被问得最多的问题是这个：威尔，你不是GMC的代言人吗？
Oh, wow. Baltimore, Washington. Did you spend time in Chicago? I thought no. All right. No. Nevermind. Did you, so did you grow up in, were the arts a big part of your life as a kid?
你是说你不能把我提到等待名单的最前面吗？如果名人朋友不能把我们提到等待名单的最前面，那有什么意义呢？这些都是好问题。要得到答案，只需访问GMC.com/SierraEV，首款全电动GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1。它是电动汽车中的Denali。GMC Sierra EV Denali Edition 1，2024年初上市，仅限预订。
Were you doing stuff, were you, how old were you when you started to perform or act or whatever? Yeah. I mean, the answer is yes. I, my folks were like really not artists, but aficionados of the theater. They loved theater. They loved film. I'm glad you said aficionado.
Sierra EV Denali，2024年春季上市。《聪明清单》得到Visible的支持。想要一个没有陷阱的无线套餐吗？那么你需要Visible。他们是一家不做陷阱的无线公司，这意味着你不需要加入家庭套餐就能省钱。Visible的单线无线套餐每月仅需30美元，包含税费，无需家庭套餐。
It's a word I would have used and it would have befuddled both of these fucking idiots, but thank you. Yeah. Yesterday, he threw out a couple of multi-syllabic words that was just. I said it and Sean squinted even more. No. I know why. You will audibly go, I sometimes keep a log of funny shit that everybody says.
你获得无限数据和热点，这意味着你可以随心所欲地从几乎任何地方流媒体播放。说真的，它完全由Verizon提供支持，没错，就是那个网络。现在他们有一个新套餐，包括5G、超宽带和全球通话。所以你获得优质的网络体验。没有陷阱是件好事。今天就切换到Visible.com，5G、超宽带和全球通话仅在Visible Plus套餐中提供，用于数据管理实践。
And as you were telling your very nice story, I started laughing at Jason saying, well, they're as dumb as you are. Yeah. So he was also on a delay, Edward. I have a little bit on a delay. The synapses are a little rusty. And now a word from our sponsor. SmartLess is supported by GMC.
在Visible.com了解更多。适用附加条款。谢谢Rocket Money的支持。听众朋友，你知道你的订阅费用到底是多少吗？大多数美国人认为他们每月在订阅上花费约80美元，而实际总额接近200多美元。没错。你可能每月在订阅上浪费数百美元。
When GMC revealed the all-electric Sierra EV Denali edition one, people had questions like how can an electric pickup deliver that much horsepower or what makes the Altium battery technology so innovative? Or even when you fold down Sierra's first ever innovative multi-pro mid-gate, where does it go? But by far the question I get asked the most about the first electric Sierra pickup is this. Will, aren't you literally the voice of GMC?
你甚至不知道。这个我们非常兴奋的应用程序可以为你处理所有这些。它叫，我刚才说了，Rocket Money。他们以前叫TrueBill，但Rocket Money听起来更有趣，对吧？这个应用程序在一个地方显示你所有的订阅，然后为你取消任何你不再想要的。Rocket Money甚至可以找到你甚至不知道自己在支付的订阅。你甚至可能发现你被重复扣费了。
Are you telling me that you can't bump me up to the front of the waitlist? And what's the point of having celebrity friends if they can't get us up to the front of the waitlist? These are all good questions. To get yours answered, just visit GMC.com backslash Sierra EV, the first ever all-electric GMC Sierra EV Denali edition one. It is the Denali of EVs. GMC Sierra EV Denali edition one, available early 2024 by reservation only.
它处理了很多事情。要取消订阅，你所要做的就是按取消，Rocket Money会处理剩下的事情。让我们现在就用Rocket Money摆脱所有无用的订阅。让我们去rocketmoney.com/smartlist。说真的，它每年可以为你节省数百美元。那是rocketmoney.com/smartlist。现在就在rocketmoney.com/smartlist取消你不必要的订阅。
Sierra EV Denali, available spring 2024. SmartList gets support from Visible. Want a wireless plan that doesn't come with a catch? Then you want Visible. They're a wireless company that doesn't do catches, which means you don't need to be on a family plan to save. Visible starts at just $30 a month for a one-line wireless plan, taxes and fees included, no family plan needed.
我不会再说一遍了。现在，回到节目。抱歉，我们正在录音，所以你的父母是爱好者，对吧？不，不。我妈妈是英语老师。她教莎士比亚和所有那类东西，但老实说，我有一个保姆在当地的戏剧艺术学校，我父母带我去看她演的一部戏，它真的点燃了我，我就开始了。
You get unlimited data and hotspot, which means you can stream as much as you want from pretty much anywhere. Seriously, it's all powered by Verizon, yep, that network. And now they have a new plan that includes 5G, ultra-wideband, and global calling. So you get a premium network experience. No catches are a good thing. Switch today at Visible.com, 5G, ultra-wideband, and global calling available only on the Visible Plus plan for data management practices.
那是《灰姑娘》吗？维基百科是对的吗？不完全是。我想那是《灰姑娘》的音乐剧之类的，但它不叫《灰姑娘》。它叫《灰姑娘》。保姆带你去看演出的？不，不，她在里面演，所以我父母带我去看这个非常，你知道。
Learn more at Visible.com. Additional terms apply. Thank you, Rocket Money, for your support. Listener, do you know how much your subscriptions really cost? Most Americans think they spend about $80 a month on subscriptions when the actual total is closer to $200 plus. That's right. You could be wasting hundreds of dollars each month on subscriptions.
嗯，但等一下。什么版本的《灰姑娘》音乐剧让你觉得“啊，我必须做那个”？因为它是一个戏剧艺术学校，你知道，在我们社区里那种常规学校之外的东西，基本上就像《等待古夫曼》，但那是给孩子们的。但因为里面有从18岁到5岁的孩子，他们会做这些每个人都有份的制作，而且这个制作里有小孩子。你觉得那可能适合我？我觉得那很酷，是的。
You don't even know about. Where is this app we're very excited about that takes care of all of that for you? And it's called, I said it earlier, Rocket Money. They're formerly known as TrueBill, but Rocket Money is just so much more fun to say, right? This app shows you all your subscriptions in one place, and then it cancels for you whatever you don't still want. Rocket Money can even find subscriptions you didn't even know you were paying for. You may even find out that you were double charged for a subscription.
我只是，那根本不是说“哦，这就是我要做的”。我只是对，你知道，如果我说足球看起来很有趣，我父母会让我去踢足球。这是我年轻时做的众多事情之一。它，你知道，是我年轻时做的众多事情之一。然后我有点，我爱它，我，我想我当时很擅长，但主要是它很有趣。这是我放学后做的事情，它很有趣，我和普通人一起做，但在高中
It takes care of so much. To cancel a subscription, all you have to do is press cancel, and Rocket Money is going to take care of the rest. Let's get rid of all the useless subscriptions with Rocket Money right now. Let's go to rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. Seriously, it could save you hundreds of dollars per year. That's rocketmoney.com slash smartlist. Cancel your unnecessary subscriptions right now at rocketmoney.com slash smartlist.
我变得非常自我，我上了公立学校。那里其实有一位非常棒的戏剧导演，但我在高中时变得超级自我意识。我很小，然后我长高了一英尺。很多是因为大麻。是的，大麻。不，我在高中时对表演之类的东西非常自我意识。所以我没有，我有点退缩了，但后来也许我16或17岁时，我想。
I'm not going to say it again. And now, back to the show. Sorry, we're in a row, so your parents were aficionados, yeah? No, no. My mom was an English teacher. She taught Shakespeare and all that kind of stuff, but honestly, I had a babysitter who was at a local theater art school, and my parents took me to see her in a thing, and it really lit me up, and I started.
我看到一个班级旅行去了华盛顿的国家剧院，伊恩·麦克莱恩正在做，他正在做这个他巡演的独角戏，是关于他在戏剧界的生活。它是关于莎士比亚的生活，莎士比亚的文本，以及他在戏剧界的生活。哦，那很酷。我不记得他叫它什么了，但它绝对令人惊叹。它，听起来，它其实听起来，现在我这么说，它听起来真的很深奥，但他，肖恩刚才在我说它深奥时又眯眼了。不，不。
Was this Cinderella? Does Wiki have that right? Not really. I think it was a musical of Cinderella or something like that, but it wasn't called Cinderella. It was called Cinderella. The babysitter brought you to the show? No, no, she was in it, so my parents took me to see this very, you know.
是的，他在抬头看。他在抬头看。不，我在抓那个。Dictionary.com。但不管怎样，我在高中旅行时看了伊恩·麦克莱恩的表演，它对我产生了很大很大的影响。我肯定。我非常，它突然看起来像是一件你可以作为成年人做的事情。
Well, but hang on a second. What was a musical version of Cinderella that was so like, ah, I got to do that? Because it was a theater art school, you know, like an outside of regular school kind of thing in our community that, like, waiting for guffman, basically, but for kids. But it was, because it had kids ranging from like 18 to five, they would do these productions where there was something for everyone, and there were little kids in this production. And you thought that might be for me? I thought that was pretty cool, yeah.
是表演的部分吗？我的意思是，如果它是，我想，准自传式的，因为他在谈论他在戏剧界的生活等等，是他描述的那种吸引你的方式吗？是的，正是如此。这是他描述的生活和他带他进入的事情的结合。但后来是他的编织，他在做莎士比亚的东西，我在高中时对莎士比亚并不太感兴趣，或者像每个人一样。你想喜欢它，但在某些方面很难进入。
And I just, it wasn't like, oh, this is what I'm going to do at all. I just was interested in, you know, if I said soccer looks fun, my parents would put me in soccer. And it was a thing I started doing like many of us. It was, you know, one among many things I did when I was young. And then I kind of, I was, I loved it, I was, I think I was good at it then, but mostly it was just fun. It was something I did after school, it was fun, I did it with regular, but in high school
尽管你母亲精通——是的，是的。不，她真的很棒，而且我认为她很擅长为孩子们阐明它。但你们记得吗，记得肯·布拉纳的《亨利五世》出来的时候吗？那可能更多是在我们上大学的时候，但不管怎样——肖恩又眯眼了。伊恩·麦克莱恩，他会做这些片段，他在谈论他的生活。然后突然他会旋转，几乎——
I got very self, I went to public school. There actually was a really great theater director there, but I got super self-conscious in high school. I was really little, and I grew like a foot. A lot of that was the weed. Yeah, the weed. No, I was very self-conscious about, in high school, about performing and stuff like that. So I wasn't, I kind of pulled back from it, but then maybe I was 16 or 17, I think.
你怎么知道你擅长这个？你还记得那个时刻吗，就像，哦，有些人说这是他们第一次让别人笑或第一次让别人哭的时候？有没有一个时刻你觉得，哦，我可能不烂？这是个好问题。我想我经历了一些阶段，当我决定，好吧，这确实让我感兴趣。然后我上了大学，然后我在打体育比赛，我并没有做太多戏剧。然后我开始再次做戏剧，我想我开始变得，你知道，我在做
I saw a class trip went down to the National Theater in DC, and Ian McKellen was doing, he was doing this one man show that he toured with that was about his life in theater. It was about Shakespeare's life, the Shakespearean texts, and his life in the theater. Oh, that's cool. I can't remember what he called it, but it was absolutely amazing. It was, it sounds, it actually sounds, now that I'm saying it, it actually sounds really sort of esoteric, but he, Sean just went it again when I said it was esoteric. No, no.
各种各样的东西。是的，但你在谈论耶鲁戏剧学院。不，不，不。我没去耶鲁戏剧学院。不，我没去耶鲁戏剧学院。我去了，我当时是——你得刷新你的页面，杰森。是的，我知道。
Yeah, he was looking up. He was looking up. No, I'm scratching that. Dictionary.com. But anyway, I saw Ian McKellen when I was in a high school trip, and it had a big, big impact on me. I'm sure. I was very, it suddenly seemed like something you could do as an adult.
你有个古怪的浏览器。你今天四次尝试都失败了。四次都失败了。你确实去了耶鲁，对吧？我去了。但我没去耶鲁的戏剧学院。不，我没有。我是历史专业的，我不是——
Was it the performance part? I mean, if it was, I guess, quasi-autobiographical in that he was talking about his life in the theater, et cetera, was him describing that alluring to you in that way? Yes, exactly. It was the combo of the life he described and the things that had taken him into. But then it was his weave, he was doing things from Shakespeare, which I wasn't super lit up on Shakespeare or something in high school, like everybody. You wanted to like it, but it was tough to get into in some ways.
我的天哪。你在开玩笑吗？威尔来了。我在旁边做戏剧，做了不少，但同样，它主要是为了好玩，我——那个想法——当我后来去纽约时，我脑子里想的是我想看看你是否能——我当时过着双重生活。我想，我要找份工作，我要做点什么，但我无法放弃对它的兴趣。
Despite your mother's proficient- Yeah, yeah. No, she was really, and she was good at illuminating it for kids, I think. But you guys remember, remember when Ken Branagh's thing, Henry V, came out? It was more maybe when we were in college, but anyway- Sean squinting again. Ian McKellen, he would do these pieces, and he was talking about his life. And then suddenly he would just sort of spin and almost-
我对电影之类的东西非常热情，但甚至不是我不爱它，或者是我没有真正给自己许可去做它。你为什么这么认为？因为我的祖父，他在我的生活中非常有影响力，他付钱让我上大学，他对我考上一所好学校感到非常兴奋和自豪。妈妈去世了还是爸爸去世了？我妈妈去世了，我和他非常亲近，我——我真的觉得——我某种程度上
How did you have any idea that you were any good at it? Do you remember that moment where it was like, oh, some people say it's the first time they make somebody laugh or the first time they make somebody cry or something? Was there a moment where you were like, oh, I might not suck at this? That's a good question. I think I went through phases when I decided, okay, this actually does interest me. Then I went to college, then I was playing sports and I wasn't really doing much theater. Then I started doing theater again and I think I started getting, you know, I was doing
欠他做点所谓的严肃的事情——你知道，我觉得我——我其实在学校时为他做过低收入住房、金融和开发工作。在日本。不，不，在纽约。天哪，你超过一千了。我不知道该死的是什么——爱德华，你和我有非常相似的轨迹，而你成功得多。
all kinds of stuff. Yeah, but you're talking about the Yale drama school. No, no, no. I didn't go to Yale drama school. No, I didn't go to Yale drama school. I went, I was like- You got to refresh your page, Jason. Yeah, I know.
那就像是你的穷人版，但我也是和我妈妈的爸爸非常亲近，他非常有影响力，帮了我很多，我也曾是历史——我短暂地退学了，不是耶鲁。我姐姐去了耶鲁。但我——所以我像是爱德华的失败者版本。埃迪。埃迪·阿内特。不，不，你的版本会是埃迪·阿内特。
You got a wonky browser. You were like, oh for four today. Oh for four. You did go to Yale, though, yes? I did. Did not go to the drama school at Yale, though. No, I did not. I was a history major and I wasn't-
我想是吧。是的。不管怎样，我每一步都和你在一起。我想说，你妈妈是老师，而你却被这些东西包围，而且你有机会接触到，我想是莎士比亚之类的东西，但我确实——我发现有趣的是，作为一个年轻演员，我发现它非常——尽管我想和它建立联系，但我发现它非常难以接近，每一步，无论出于什么原因，这只是我个人，当涉及到那样的文本时，我就是找不到切入点。
Oh my God. Are you kidding? There comes Will. I was doing theater on the side, a fair amount of it, but again, it was mostly just fun and I- the idea- when I went to New York after, it was in the back of my mind that I wanted to see whether you could- I kind of was having a double life. I was like, I'm going to get a job, I'm going to do something, but I couldn't kind of let go of this interest in it.
无论它是肯·布拉纳，还是25年前我在百老汇看雷·费因斯演《哈姆雷特》，我不知道你是否看过——每次我试图和它建立联系，我都觉得非常非常困难，我不知道为什么，我想我现在比那时更能欣赏它了。那时它对我来说有点浪费。你知道我的意思吗？我知道，是的。我确实认为像雷这样的人，我见过——比如他演了《安东尼与克莉奥佩特拉》，那是一部很难的
I was very passionate about film and stuff like that, but it wasn't even that I didn't love it or it was that I wasn't really giving myself permission to do it. And why do you think so? Because my granddad, who was very influential in my life, he paid for me to go to college and he was very excited and proud about the fact that I'd gotten into a good school and all these things. Mom's dead or dad's dead? My mom's dead and I was very close with him and he- I really actually felt- I sort of
戏，但他是能够阐明它的人，他能够让你知道它到底是什么，也就是步入中年并想再次找到激情，我确实见过能够以特殊方式让它再次焕发生机的人。我不是其中之一，我在大学里做过一些莎士比亚的东西，但有时它感觉更像是一个人在职业生涯中打勾，而不是。我喜欢它，但我喜欢在看到那些有这种能力的人时去欣赏它，但我总是更被那些感觉像——我能用它做什么，那是不适合我的，我能用它做什么让它变得新颖，或者什么，你知道，我不知道。
owed him doing something quote unquote serious with my- you know, I felt like I- and I actually kind of worked for him in doing low income housing, finance and development when I got into school. In Japan. No, no, in New York. Boy, you're over a thousand. I don't know what the fuck- Edward, you and I have very similar tracks and yours is much more successful.
欠他去做一些所谓的正经事，你知道，我觉得我——实际上我在上学时还为他工作过，做低收入住房的金融和开发。在日本。不，不，在纽约。天哪，你已经超过一千了。我不知道到底——爱德华，你和我的轨迹非常相似，而你成功得多。
That is like the poor man's version of you, but I also was very close to my mom's dad and he was very influential and helped me out a lot and I also was a history- briefly I dropped out of college and not Yale. My sister went to Yale. But I- so I'm like the loser version of Edward. Eddie. Eddie Arnett. No, no, no, your version would be Eddie Arnett.
那就像是穷人版的你，但我跟我外公也很亲，他对我影响很大，帮了我很多，而且我也曾是历史系——我短暂地退过学，不是耶鲁。我姐姐去了耶鲁。但我——所以我就像是爱德华的失败版。埃迪。埃迪·阿内特。不，不，不，你的版本应该是埃迪·阿内特。
I guess so. Yeah. Anyway, I'm with you every step of the way. I was going to say it's funny that your mom was a teacher and yet you were surrounded by this and you had access to I guess things like Shakespeare or whatever, but I do- I find it interesting that as a young actor, I found it very- as much as I wanted to connect with it, I found it very inaccessible and every step of the way, for whatever reason, this is just me personally, when it came to text like that, I just couldn't find an access.
我想是吧。是啊。总之，我每一步都支持你。我本来想说，很有趣的是，你妈妈是老师，而你却被这些东西包围，并且接触到了比如莎士比亚之类的作品，但我确实觉得很有意思，作为一个年轻演员，我发现它非常——尽管我很想与之产生共鸣，但我发现它很难接近，无论出于什么原因，每一步都是如此，这只是我个人的感受，当涉及到那样的文本时，我就是找不到切入点。
It doesn't matter whether it was Kenneth Branagh, I saw Ray Fiennes do Hamlet on Broadway 25 years ago, I don't know if you saw- like every time I tried to connect with it, I found it very, very difficult and I don't know why and I think I can appreciate it more now than I did then. It was kind of wasted on me then. Do you know what I mean? I do, yeah. I do think people like Ray who I've seen- like he did Antony and Cleopatra, which is a tough
不管是肯尼斯·布拉纳，还是我25年前在百老汇看雷·费因斯演的《哈姆雷特》，我不知道你有没有看过——就像每次我试图与之产生共鸣时，我都觉得非常非常困难，我不知道为什么，我想我现在比当时更能欣赏它了。当时对我来说有点浪费。你明白我的意思吗？我明白，是的。我确实认为像雷这样的人——我见过他演《安东尼与克莉奥佩特拉》，那是一部很难的
play like not, but he was able to illuminate it, he was able to let you know what it was really about with it, which is becoming middle aged and wanting to find passion again and I've definitely seen people who are able to bring it to life again in a special way. I'm not one of them, I did some Shakespeare stuff in college, but sometimes it almost felt more like a box that someone's ticking in a career than it did. I love it, but I love going to it when I see people who have that, but I was always drawn much more to things that felt like, what could I do with that that's- it doesn't fit me and what could I do with it that can make it new or what, you know, I don't know.
剧，不是吗，但他能够阐明它，他能让你知道它真正讲的是什么，也就是步入中年并渴望重新寻找激情，我确实见过有人能以一种特殊的方式让它重获新生。我不是其中之一，我在大学里演过一些莎士比亚的作品，但有时感觉这更像是职业生涯中需要打勾的任务，而不是其他。我喜欢它，但我喜欢在看到那些有天赋的人表演时去欣赏，但我总是更被那些让我觉得‘我能用它做什么’的东西所吸引，那些不适合我的东西，我能用它做些什么让它变得新颖，或者什么，你知道，我不知道。
I always like the blank page. I feel like it's more like it might be like performative, like I've got to do the Shakespeare as it is intended to be done as opposed to a free ball character that's written in an original screenplay that you have total autonomy over and you can create a brand new person. The interaction with the others, you know, with the writer, with the director, to try to like pour something into a mold and come up with something interesting together. And look, I'm not saying that doesn't happen when people do classical stuff. You strike me as somebody who definitely has a very specific idea or plan about the way
我一直很喜欢空白页。我觉得这更像是一种表演，就像我必须按照莎士比亚原本的意图去演绎，而不是像在原创剧本中那样，你可以拥有完全的自主权，去塑造一个全新的角色。与他人——编剧、导演——的互动，试图将某种东西注入模具，共同创造出有趣的东西。听着，我并不是说人们在做古典作品时就不会发生这种情况。你给我的印象是，对于你将要扮演的角色，你绝对有一个非常具体的想法或计划。
in which you're going to play a character, and yet you have worked with some of the greatest directors of our time that are famous for having a very specific idea or plan about the way in which they're going to make their film. You're asking if you're getting to, did you clash with all these directors? It's not the way I would have phrased it, but my question is, was that a calculated risk that you were taking or were you excited to work for them in their films or it seemed like, you know. I'm assuming it's Deftus Mucci that's made you think of Mike.
然而，你曾与我们这个时代一些最伟大的导演合作过，他们以对电影的拍摄方式有着非常具体的想法或计划而闻名。你是在问我是否与这些导演发生过冲突吗？这不是我会用的措辞，但我的问题是，那是一个你所承担的经过计算的风险，还是你很兴奋能为他们的电影工作，或者看起来像是……我猜是达斯汀·霍夫曼让你想到了迈克。
Yeah, but these directors are the best at what they do and might not be that flexible to accommodate your question. Actually, I mean, tell me if you relate to this, I bet you do. There are some people, a Spike Lee, a David Fincher, Wes Anderson, the specificity of the way they do it is so liberating to me. It's so great to just, and I'm not saying it's puppetry, I'm not saying they're not looking for you to bring an inflection or whatever, but I think that in film anyway, when someone's in such command of the style that they're going to work in and you can
是的，但这些导演在他们的领域是最好的，可能不会那么灵活地去迁就你的问题。其实，我是说，告诉我你是否有同感，我敢打赌你有。有些人，比如斯派克·李、大卫·芬奇、韦斯·安德森，他们那种做事方式的明确性对我来说是一种解脱。能这样真是太棒了，我不是说这是提线木偶，我不是说他们不需要你带来某种语调或什么的，但我认为至少在电影中，当一个人如此掌控他将要工作的风格，而你能够
just fit into it, I find that really liberating. Who was primal for your first film? I auditioned for it. Not you, Sean. And we're going on the show today. But I did. Yeah, it was. It was.
融入其中时，我发现这真的很令人解脱。谁是你的第一部电影《一级恐惧》的导演？我去试镜了。不是你，肖恩。我们今天在节目里。但我确实去了。是的，确实是。
And I think I might have passed Sean in the lobby of Gulf and Western Building in New York. You remember because he... He told that once on the show. Did you... I did, yeah, I remember that. Did you really? Oh, you actually did?
我想我可能在纽约海湾与西方大厦的大厅里和肖恩擦肩而过。你记得是因为他……他曾在节目里讲过那件事。你……我确实记得，是的。你真的记得吗？哦，你真的记得？
I did. I got like two or three callbacks. It was in Chicago. I was like 22 years old. I'm still waiting to hear. I remember we were talking to, Matt Damon was on the show and he referenced you and that part. Yeah, it's amazing.
我记得。我大概有两三次复试。那是在芝加哥。我当时大概22岁。我还在等消息。我记得我们和马特·达蒙聊天时，他在节目里提到了你和那个角色。是的，太神奇了。
You were incredible in that. Yeah, for sure. Oh my God. But Matt tells a story about how he and Ben, before they wrote, what you call it? Good Will Hunting. Good Will Hunting, yeah. That was like, well, there's only one primal fear part in a generation and Edward just got it.
你在那部戏里表现得太棒了。是的，当然。天哪。但马特讲过一个故事，说他和本在写那个，叫什么来着？《心灵捕手》。《心灵捕手》，对。那就像是，好吧，一代人里只有一个《一级恐惧》的角色，而爱德华得到了它。
So we better start writing. We got to write something for us to do. Oh, that's good. Yeah. It was a big deal. I actually helped a casting director in New York as they were doing an open casting for it. And I was like, can I read?
所以我们最好开始写。我们得写点东西让我们自己演。哦，那太好了。是的。那是一件大事。我当时实际上在纽约帮一位选角导演做公开选角。我就问，我可以读一下吗？
No, no, no. Why don't you just help us? And we're not interested in seeing you. And I was like, this is great. Well, this is fantastic for my ego, but yeah. You're reading the part of Carol and you're queuing in. They asked you to read for the Connie Britton role. Yeah, they did.
不，不，不。你为什么不帮我们呢？我们没兴趣看你表演。我就想，这太棒了。好吧，这对我的自尊心来说太棒了，但确实。你在读卡罗尔的角色，你在给别人对戏。他们让你读康妮·布里顿的角色。是的，他们确实这么做了。
No, I asked to. I asked to. And it is a compliment because they saw you as too masculine to be a stuttering altar boy who gets raped. They were like, no one would buy it. No one would buy this guy as a victim. Now, was your interest in, I apologize for being all over the place. I'm a disaster, but was your interest in philanthropy and business and investments and stuff like
不，是我要求的。是我要求的。这其实是一种恭维，因为他们觉得你太阳刚了，不适合演一个被强奸的口吃祭坛男孩。他们觉得没人会相信。没人会相信这家伙是个受害者。那么，你对慈善、商业、投资之类的兴趣，
that? You were a part of kind of who you are and yeah. Yeah. Those are different. Within those categories, I'd say my family's been very involved in kind of, I want to say philanthropic, their work is my dad's a great conservation advocate, attorney. He's a phenomenal leader in the conservation and land conservation movement. My grandfather was a famous developer, but was involved in affordable housing very deeply
是……那是你的一部分，是的。是的。那些是不同的。在这些类别中，我想说我的家庭一直非常投入，我想说的是慈善，他们的工作……我父亲是一位伟大的自然保护倡导者、律师。他是自然保护和土地保护运动中杰出的领导者。我祖父是一位著名的开发商，但非常深入地参与了经济适用房项目，
and my mother was in education reform. So I grew up in a world of people swirling around me who were doing all kinds of mission driven kind of cause related work that was very passionate and very inspiring. The funny thing is a lot of that sounds noble when you say it a certain way, but the truth is, the thing that was coolest about my family was they were just all having a ball. My dad loved and still loves, he's 80, the work he did. He was inspired by like John Muir and Ed Abbey and Aldo Leopold and like all these, you know, these great-
而我母亲从事教育改革。所以我成长在一个周围环绕着各种从事使命驱动型事业的人的世界里，他们充满激情，非常鼓舞人心。有趣的是，当你以某种方式说出来时，很多听起来都很高尚，但事实是，关于我家庭最酷的事情是他们都乐在其中。我父亲热爱，现在仍然热爱，他80岁了，他所做的工作。他受到约翰·缪尔、埃德·阿比和奥尔多·利奥波德等人的启发，还有所有这些，你知道，这些伟大的——
More hay squinting. Yeah. The great American conservation kind of warriors, David Brower and he was like, he wanted to be outside. He wanted to be fighting for these like great places and in them. When we were kids, it was just like the work my dad did just seemed like the ultimate fun. Then as you started to accrue a crew capital and influence, it was natural for you to say, well, let me channel some of that towards, let's shine some of the light on these issues.
更多干草眯眼。是的。伟大的美国自然保护战士，大卫·布劳尔，他就像，他想待在户外。他想为这些伟大的地方而战，并身处其中。当我们还是孩子的时候，我父亲所做的工作看起来就像终极乐趣。然后当你开始积累资本和影响力时，你自然会说，好吧，让我把其中的一些引导向……让我们把光芒照向这些问题。
And yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, I always found that work, the stuff I've done working on conservation related stuff environmental work, I find it very adventurous. I think it's, you know, it's, I mean, it's fun to play people in this weird gig we do, but it's also fun to like actually get out and really help the world. Live a life.
是的。是的。是的。我是说，我一直觉得那项工作，我所做的关于自然保护相关的工作，环境工作，我觉得非常有冒险精神。我认为，你知道，我是说，在我们从事的这个奇怪的行业里扮演不同的人很有趣，但真正走出去并真正帮助这个世界也很有趣。过一种生活。
Yeah. Sean, one time hired a private jet to bring milkshakes back from Chicago on their own. Holy shit. What's the name of that place? What's the issue? Portillo's. Portillo's. Yeah.
是的。肖恩有一次雇了一架私人飞机，专门从芝加哥带回奶昔。天哪。那个地方叫什么名字？是什么问题？Portillo's。Portillo's。是的。
That's a joke. Well, while we're there, while we're on, you know, charities that deserve some attention. If you had a free billion dollars that would you found in your pocket, you have to channel it somewhere. Well, these aren't charities. These are causes. These are. Okay.
那是开玩笑的。好吧，既然我们在这儿，既然我们谈到了，你知道，值得关注的慈善机构。如果你口袋里凭空多出十亿美元，你必须把它投向某个地方。好吧，这些不是慈善机构。这些是事业。这些是。好的。
No, but that, that, that would not be difficult for me. I, I've spent a, I would, where would you put it? You got to put it one place. One place. That, that's. Peel off a hondo for me. Don't be a dick. Yeah.
不，但那，那对我来说并不难。我，我花了一，我会，你会把它放在哪里？你必须把它放在一个地方。一个地方。那，那。给我撕下一张百元大钞。别混蛋。是的。
Peel off a hondo. Where do you think it most be used to today as opposed to last year or in 10 years? I guess, you know, without getting too into the weeds, I think global conservation and environmental protection that's gone from sort of this idea of preservation through defense, you know, like putting lines around places and protecting them and creating protecting areas to people. I'd say there's a more sophisticated understanding now than there was even when I was in college that, you know, these, these complex systems wrap the world and you really, you really
撕下一张百元大钞。你认为今天把它用在哪里最合适，而不是去年或10年后？我想，你知道，不深入细节的话，我认为全球自然保护和环境保护已经从那种通过防御进行保护的想法，你知道，比如在地方周围划线并保护它们，创造保护区，转向了人。我想说，现在比我上大学时有了更复杂的理解，你知道，这些复杂的系统包裹着世界，你真的，你真的
can't like, you can't, you basically have to bring the way that eight billion people are living in line with ecological sustainability. You can't separate like our economies from it. So you, to me, the most exciting thing that's happening now is that I think people are really coming to understand that you've got to value nature and natural systems within our economic framework and that when you price it the right way, when you, when you understand that air and water and biodiverse, all these things actually aren't free. You can build new, very interesting models of, you know, you can have the poor people
不能像，你不能，你基本上必须使八十亿人的生活方式与生态可持续性保持一致。你不能把我们的经济从中剥离出来。所以，对我来说，现在正在发生的最令人兴奋的事情是，我认为人们真的开始理解，你必须在我们的经济框架内重视自然和自然系统，当你以正确的方式定价时，当你，当你理解空气、水和生物多样性，所有这些东西实际上并不是免费的。你可以建立新的、非常有趣的模式，你知道，你可以让地球上
in the planet who live on the front lines of the places that we're degrading. You got to come up with better economic outcomes for people from sustainably managing like the planet, then, then trashing it. And that's, that's, that's what I think is most interesting today is that we're. We can't wall ourselves off and then continue to live in the same manner that we have to do, accept where we live and, and change the way that we live and our attitudes and our perspectives towards the environment in which we live. And does some of that also still include reclamation of, of various lands and that's as well?
那些生活在我们正在破坏的地方前线的贫困人口。你必须为人们想出比破坏地球更好的经济成果，通过可持续地管理地球。这就是，这就是，这就是我认为今天最有趣的事情，我们不能把自己围起来，然后继续以同样的方式生活，我们必须接受我们居住的地方，并改变我们的生活方式以及我们对所处环境的态度和视角。这其中是否还包括对各种土地的开垦，这也是吗？
Or is that a not, not as worthy? Oh, no, for sure. But I think with a different understanding, I think of which, which degradations hurt us the most and what kinds of restorations actually deliver value. If I, you know, we're all friends with Dax, I don't, I don't know if you happen to hear this one interview he did recently with this guy named George Monbiot. It's, it's, you know, anything, but it is, if I've heard one person recently articulate these macro dynamics, absolutely brilliantly, that interview is anyone who's interested
还是说那不是，不是那么有价值？哦，不，当然。但我认为要有不同的理解，我认为哪些破坏对我们的伤害最大，什么样的恢复实际上能带来价值。如果我，你知道，我们都是达克斯的朋友，我不知道你是否碰巧听过他最近对一个叫乔治·蒙比奥的人做的采访。这，这，你知道，任何事情，但如果我最近听到一个人如此出色地阐述这些宏观动态，那次采访是任何感兴趣的人
in just sort of where. What was his name again? Dax Shepard. I don't know if I'm pronouncing it. You know him actually. What's Dax short for? He's, he's, I've always wondered Dax a million. You've always, it's just Dax.
只是那种……他叫什么名字来着？达克斯·夏普德。我不知道我发音对不对。你其实认识他。达克斯是哪个词的缩写？他，他，我一直很好奇达克斯一百万。你一直，这只是达克斯。
We'll be right back. SmartList is supported by Audible. You know what? I love Audible so much. I'm going to try a new pronunciation every time we do it. This time I'm going to try outie bleh. You don't ride an elevator for the music or pick an airline for the movies. So when it comes to audio entertainment, it makes sense to choose outie bleh.
我们马上回来。SmartList由Audible支持。你知道吗？我太喜欢Audible了。每次我们做节目时，我都要尝试一种新的发音。这次我要尝试“outie bleh”。你不会为了音乐去坐电梯，也不会为了电影去选航空公司。所以当谈到音频娱乐时，选择“outie bleh”是有道理的。
It's the home for stories told by the biggest stars like Ethan Hawke, Kerry Washington and Kevin Hart. It's the home to epic adventures, chilly mysteries and can't miss comedies. Outie bleh is the home of storytelling. Let your imagination soar with audio books, podcasts and originals. You know what's cool about Audible? When you put your earbuds in and you're listening to something on Audible, I can be like walking amongst, you know, the humans on this earth, but it transports me to like another planet.
它是伊桑·霍克、凯丽·华盛顿和凯文·哈特等大明星讲述故事的家园。它是史诗冒险、惊悚悬疑和不可错过的喜剧的家园。“outie bleh”是讲故事的家园。用有声读物、播客和原创作品让你的想象力飞翔。你知道Audible最酷的地方是什么吗？当你戴上耳机，在Audible上听东西时，我可以像是在地球上的人类中行走，但它把我带到了另一个星球。
It's the coolest feeling. So like for example, right now I'm, I'm checking out the immortality thief. It's really, really cool. I got this guy, this, this like smuggler who is blackmailed into a job to get some data off an ancient ship, but it's, you know, but you can tell by the title, it's like maybe something that has to do with immortality. So unfortunately he's not the only one looking. I'll just leave it at that.
这是最酷的感觉。所以，比如现在，我正在看《不朽窃贼》。它真的很酷。我有一个家伙，这个，这个像是走私者，被勒索去执行一项任务，从一艘古老的船上获取一些数据，但你知道，但你可以从标题看出来，它可能与不朽有关。所以不幸的是，他不是唯一一个在寻找的人。我就说到这儿。
It's really, really cool. I must listen. I was gonna say I must read, but it's must listen. So if you get a chance, immortality thief, outie bleh is the home of storytelling with all your audio entertainment in one app. Find the best of what you love or something new to discover. Outie bleh has an incredible selection of audio books across every genre from best sellers and new releases to celebrity memoirs, mysteries and thrillers, motivation, wellness, business
它真的很酷。必听。我本来想说必读，但它是必听。所以如果你有机会，听听《不朽窃贼》，“outie bleh”是讲故事的家园，所有的音频娱乐都在一个应用程序中。找到你所爱的最好的东西，或者发现一些新的东西。“outie bleh”拥有令人难以置信的有声读物选择，涵盖了从畅销书和新书到名人回忆录、悬疑和惊悚、励志、健康、商业等每一个流派
and more as an outie bleh member. You can choose one title a month to keep from their entire catalog, including the latest best sellers and new releases. Members also get full access to a growing selection of included audio books, audible originals and podcasts. You can download or stream our included titles all you want. Let audible help you discover new ways to laugh, be inspired or be entertained. New members can try it for free for 30 days.
等等。作为“outie bleh”会员，你可以每月从他们的整个目录中选择一个标题保留，包括最新的畅销书和新书。会员还可以完全访问精选的有声读物、Audible原创作品和播客。你可以随意下载或流式传输我们包含的标题。让Audible帮助你发现欢笑、获得灵感或娱乐的新方式。新会员可以免费试用30天。
Visit audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartlist or text smartlist to 500-500 to try audible free for 30 days, audible.com slash smartlist. Back to the show. Now I want to shift gears and I want to talk about one of my favorite, there have been a few times over the years where I've watched people on a late night show tell a great story. One of my favorite stories that I've repeated many times is you on Letterman describing working on the score with two of your idols.
访问audible.com/smartlist或发送短信smartlist到500-500。那是audible.com/smartlist或发送短信smartlist到500-500，免费试用Audible 30天，audible.com/smartlist。回到节目。现在我想换个话题，我想谈谈我最喜欢的之一，多年来有几次我看着人们在深夜节目中讲一个伟大的故事。我重复过很多次的最喜欢的故事之一就是你在莱特曼节目上描述与你的两个偶像一起制作配乐。
It's one of my favorite stories. Please tell it. I don't know it. And it's a little fuzzy because it was a few years ago, it was about 20 years ago. A few. Yeah. Yeah. But do you remember that, do you remember telling Dave that story?
这是我最喜欢的故事之一。请讲出来。我不知道它。而且有点模糊，因为那是几年前的事了，大约20年前。几年。是的。是的。但你还记得吗，你还记得告诉戴夫那个故事吗？
You know what is the only, the ego narrows what you remember. And of course what I remember in that is imitating them maybe and Letterman goes, you are a regular rich little, my friend. He compared me to rich little. Which is a high compliment. Yeah. Famous person. Long before everybody was doing Matt McConaughey and their imitations, rich little was the
你知道什么是唯一的吗？自我会缩小你的记忆。当然，我记得的是模仿他们，也许莱特曼说，你真是个典型的里奇·利特尔，我的朋友。他把我比作里奇·利特尔。这可是很高的评价。是的。名人。在每个人都在模仿马修·麦康纳之前，里奇·利特尔就是
guy, right? He was the guy. He was amazing. He was the impersonation guy. Also Canadian. Yeah. He was. Yeah.
那个人，对吧？他就是那个人。他太棒了。他是模仿大师。也是加拿大人。是的。他是。是的。
It was a good pull anyway. So if you don't remember it, the way, I'm going to do it so that you don't have to, which was, unless you do remember it. No. Of course I remember it was, I would like to hear it if you'd like to tell it. You were describing working with two of your, you know, of course acting sort of idols, if you will. Yes.
总之，这是一个很好的梗。所以如果你不记得了，方式是，我要讲出来，这样你就不用讲了，除非你记得。不。我当然记得，如果你们想听，我很乐意讲。你当时在描述与你的，你知道，当然是表演偶像，如果你愿意的话，一起工作。是的。
Well, it was Marlon Brando's last movie. I had known him prior to doing it. Robert De Niro kind of pulled him and me into this film. He wanted to do it. And he was the one who sort of recruit, I credit him with the idea that it would be interesting for the three of us to line up in this kind of multi-generational heist thing. I think that Bob was getting a really big paycheck and he didn't want it to fall apart also and he was thinking like, how can I hold it together with people I like and blah, blah.
嗯，那是马龙·白兰度的最后一部电影。在做那部电影之前我就认识他。罗伯特·德尼罗把我和他拉进了这部电影。他想做这部电影。而且是他那种招募，我归功于他，他认为我们三个人在某种多代抢劫的事情中排成一列会很有趣。我想鲍勃当时拿到了一笔很大的片酬，他也不想让它泡汤，他就在想，我怎么能把我喜欢的人聚在一起，等等等等。
And anyway, he pulled us all together and it was the kind of thing I would have really done just for the poster, you know, I mean, you really like, like the whole idea that it would say, you know, Brando De Niro, Affleck would have really, you know, it would, I would have been on the show saying, why did I let that one get away? You know what I mean? There's only one of that because they, and they had never done a movie together. The Godfather movies, but they weren't in the same scenes. Yeah.
总之，他把我们都聚在一起，这简直是我为了海报就会做的事情，你知道，我的意思是，你真的喜欢，就像整个想法是它会写着，你知道，白兰度、德尼罗、阿弗莱克，真的会，你知道，我会出现在节目上说，我为什么让那个机会溜走了？你知道我的意思吗？那种机会只有一次，因为他们，他们以前从未一起拍过电影。《教父》电影，但他们不在同一个场景里。是的。
So it was kind of like, you know, I need to get on that set just for the story. And then it was really great. It actually was, even though it was kind of a genre movie and it had its formulaic qualities, I did actually think they were both really great and Marlon had this idea that was not in the script that he used to, you know, he got a lot of flak from people for being a little bit of an anarchist or being things. And I didn't actually think it was warranted. I thought that Marlon would, if he thought you were going to venerate him, if he thought
所以这就像是，你知道，我需要进入那个片场，仅仅是为了那个故事。然后它真的很棒。实际上确实如此，尽管它有点像类型片，而且有其公式化的特质，但我确实认为他们两个都很棒，马龙有一个剧本里没有的想法，他过去常常，你知道，他因为有点无政府主义或某些事情而受到很多人的抨击。我实际上认为这并不合理。我认为马龙，如果他认为你要崇拜他，如果他认为
you were going to be one of those, you know, kind of gooey, I'm talking to Marlon Brando, he would really stick a fork in you and he didn't like it. He wanted to... Well, he sure liked to stick forks in things. We know that. Yeah. Good. That was a layup.
你要成为那种，你知道，那种黏糊糊的，我在和马龙·白兰度说话，他真的会用叉子戳你，他不喜欢那样。他想……嗯，他确实喜欢用叉子戳东西。我们知道这一点。是的。好。那是个简单的投篮。
I was like, thank you. Sorry. But he had this idea that his character was in love with Bob's character and that he, you know, and I think a lot of people honestly kind of got, went a little gripped, like, oh God, what is he doing? He's going to, he's, you know, he's coming up with the idea of this character, this tough heist movie and suddenly he's acting like, you know, Truman Capote and everything. But the thing was, is, I'm going to say this though, when you have an idea in your head
我当时想，谢谢。抱歉。但他有这个想法，他的角色爱上了鲍勃的角色，而且他，你知道，我认为很多人老实说有点被抓住了，就像，哦天哪，他在做什么？他要，他，你知道，他想出了这个角色的想法，这部硬汉抢劫电影，突然间他表现得像，你知道，杜鲁门·卡波特等等。但事情是，我要说的是，当你脑子里有一个想法
about what something's going to be and someone else does something else, you can tighten up, right, and not pay attention to whether there's really something in that idea. And the truth is, I think everybody was reacting to, oh, we got Brando De Niro and Edward, and these things, it's going to be tough, it's going to be great. And Marlon had this totally different idea, which was that he was in love with Bob. But it's, it's fantastic, it's a fantastic idea. And it is great in the film. You can feel, you feel that the hold in their relationship has been this longstanding, unrequited
关于某件事会是什么样子，而别人做了别的事情，你可以收紧，对吧，不去注意那个想法里是否真的有什么东西。事实是，我认为每个人都在反应，哦，我们有白兰度和德尼罗和爱德华，这些事情，这会很艰难，这会很棒。而马龙有一个完全不同的想法，那就是他爱上了鲍勃。但这，这太棒了，这是一个绝妙的想法。而且在电影里真的很棒。你可以感觉到，你感觉到他们关系中的那种坚持是一种长期的、未被回应的
thing. And it's much more, I mean, who's tougher or more stoic than Bob? It's not, what's the value of doubling up on it, right? But if you watch Brando in that movie, it's really, really good what he's doing. He's lighter. He plays a character who's, it adds a whole other layer to the film that wasn't in there and it's really good. And I thought it was kind of a shame in a way that he, he kind of got, you know, painted
东西。而且它更，我是说，谁比鲍勃更强硬或更坚忍？加倍努力有什么价值，对吧？但如果你看白兰度在那部电影里的表现，他所做的事情真的非常好。他更轻盈。他扮演的角色，这为电影增加了一层原本没有的层面，而且真的很好。我觉得在某种程度上有点遗憾，他，他有点被，你知道，涂上了
with the like, oh, he's just, he's being disruptive. He's being, he's been, for what, for like proposing that the character might, you know, have a thing for Bob. You know, it's like, what? But you guys had this, but you have this big scene where the three of you and he's drinking sparkling water. This is the moment that you described. Good memory.
那种，哦，他只是，他很具破坏性。他很，他被，为了什么，为了提议角色可能，你知道，对鲍勃有意思？你知道，这就像，什么？但你们有这个，但你们有一个大场景，你们三个人，他在喝气泡水。这就是你描述的那个时刻。好记性。
God, I didn't even remember. Yeah. Yes. Now I know what you're talking about. Now I know what you're talking about. Remlosa sparkling water, by the way, to be specific, I have a crazy, weird memory. So I think, I think it was aqua mineral, is it? Oh, you might be right.
天哪，我甚至都不记得了。是的。是的。现在我知道你在说什么了。现在我知道你在说什么了。顺便说一句，Remlosa气泡水，具体来说，我有一个疯狂的、奇怪的记忆。所以我认为，我认为是矿泉水，是吗？哦，你可能是对的。
Oh, crap. And he, he, no, you're, now I know what you're talking about. I didn't know what you're talking about. Yes. He, it was the first scene with the three, it was the first scene that we got to do together, the three of us. And, and I allowed myself a little bit of a moment of, you know, I'm walking with giants like this is amazing.
哦，该死。而他，他，不，你，现在我知道你在说什么了。我不知道你在说什么。是的。他，那是我们三个人的第一个场景，那是我们三个在一起做的第一个场景。而且，我允许自己有一点，你知道，我和巨人同行，这太神奇了。
And in the first take, Marlon is, we're pitching the heist to De Niro. And Marlon has this riff and then I'm supposed to have a little riff and then Bob is supposed to have this reaction. So De Niro is, you know, just listening and very stoic and intense. And Marlon's telling this very flowery story and it's a big tracking shot with all three of us and they, they call it and Marlon goes right into it. And he's really terrific. He's, he's, he's funny.
在第一次拍摄中，马龙是，我们在向德尼罗推销抢劫计划。马龙有一个即兴表演，然后我应该有一个小即兴表演，然后鲍勃应该有这个反应。所以德尼罗是，你知道，只是在听，非常坚忍和专注。马龙在讲一个非常华丽的故事，这是一个有我们三个人的大跟踪镜头，他们，他们喊停，马龙直接进入状态。他真的很棒，他，他很有趣。
He's rye. He's saying this thing and he's talking about how a shipment got hung up in custom because of Asian longhorn beetles or something. And he's saying, you know, in hamburgers was the fucking bugs. And he's, and he's saying this thing and he says Asian longhorn beetles, they got inside the crate and he's put, and he starts pouring his water into the glass. He's very fluid and he's terrific in the scene. But I notice that he's, he's very in it.
他很冷幽默。他在说这件事，他在谈论一批货物是如何因为亚洲天牛或其他什么东西而在海关被扣留的。他在说，你知道，在汉堡包里是该死的虫子。他在，他在说这件事，他说亚洲天牛，它们钻进了板条箱，他正在放，他开始把水倒进杯子里。他非常流畅，他在场景中表现得非常出色。但我注意到他，他非常投入。
He's looking at De Niro and he's pouring the water down the outside of the glass onto his own linen shirt and it's pooling on his stomach in this little pool in his linen, a cup in his linen shirt and filling the shirt. And I go to look at De Niro like, is he, how's he going to react to this? And Bob was falling asleep. He'd been up very late and he was listening, but he was, he was actually starting to nod out and then, then someone says, cut and Bob snaps up and looks at me and he says, was I falling asleep?
他看着德尼罗，他把水倒在杯子外面，倒在他自己的亚麻衬衫上，它在他的胃上汇聚成一个小水池，在他的亚麻衬衫里，在他的亚麻衬衫里形成一个杯子，填满了衬衫。我去看着德尼罗，就像，他，他会对此有什么反应？而鲍勃正在睡着。他熬得很晚，他在听，但他，他实际上开始打瞌睡了，然后，然后有人喊，停，鲍勃猛地抬起头看着我说，我刚才睡着了吗？
And I said, I nodded like really hesitantly and he started, he goes, oh, that's the first, you know, and I was like, one of them is pouring water down his stomach and the other is falling asleep. He's falling asleep. He's walking with these, oh God, I fuck that is stuck with me. I have told that story. That's so funny. Three dozen times.
我说，我非常犹豫地点了点头，他开始，他说，哦，那是第一次，你知道，我当时想，其中一个把水倒在自己的胃上，另一个正在睡着。他正在睡着。他正和这些人一起走，哦天哪，我该死的那件事一直困扰着我。我讲过那个故事。太搞笑了。三打次。
So all of the, I mean, I'm so sort of in on humble by your intelligence, your thoughtfulness, all that. What do you, what do you do that's the, what's the lowest brow thing you do? The dumb guy. Sometimes I, oh. Lowest brow. I mean, like, is it, is it, is it a, you love to listen to a shitty disco? Do you, do you watch a gravity reality show?
所以所有这些，我是说，我被你的智慧、你的深思熟虑所折服。你，你做什么，什么是你做的最没品位的事情？笨蛋。有时我，哦。最没品位。我是说，比如，是，是，你喜欢听烂迪斯科吗？你，你看那种垃圾真人秀吗？
Low Brown. Do you have a sugar addiction? What, what? Yeah. I'm always, I have a terrible, I'm terrible with like, I'm like, Sean, I drink coffee as an excuse for milk and sugar, but see, we bonded, Sean, we bonded. So all right. No, no.
没品位。你有糖瘾吗？什么，什么？是的。我总是，我有一个糟糕的，我不擅长，比如，我像，肖恩，我喝咖啡是为了借口加牛奶和糖，但看，我们建立了联系，肖恩，我们建立了联系。所以好吧。不，不。
I don't know. I don't know. You know, it's funny. I just did this. You said you had Ryan Johnson on. Yeah. Yeah. So I did, I did this knives out.
我不知道。我不知道。你知道，这很有趣。我刚做了这个。你说你有瑞安·约翰逊。是的。是的。所以我做了，我做了这个《利刃出鞘》。
Right. Glass onion coming out. Yeah. It's coming out. And it's, and he, I mean, you, you saw what a dry humor. I mean, he, that guy is just so sweet. That guy is, is really sweet and iconic and laid back, but holy shit, is he funny? And he's, you talk about someone who, you were saying like, what's the low thing you
对。《玻璃洋葱》要出来了。是的。它要出来了。而且他，我是说，你，你看到了多么干巴巴的幽默。我是说，他，那个家伙真是太甜了。那个家伙，是真的很甜，标志性且随和，但该死，他很有趣吗？而且他，你在谈论某人，你当时说，什么是你做的低级的事情？
do? But when we were doing that film, you know, sometimes you know how this is, sometimes you're doing a thing, right? You're doing a thing and you're like, how low can we go in this? Like how, what, what level? What's the right level? Because it was really funny, but is it all highbrow funny or is some of it slapstick Yeah.
但是当我们拍那部电影时，你知道，有时你知道这是怎么回事，有时你在做一件事，对吧？你在做一件事，你在想，我们在这件事上能走多低？就像，什么，什么水平？什么是正确的水平？因为它真的很有趣，但它是所有高雅的有趣，还是其中一些是闹剧，是的。
you know, physical comedy funny, or are we allowed, you know, a joke that's down here in, in. Tonal shirts. Yeah. And he, he just, you know, sometimes like you get this feeling that a director's not really sure and is willing to take everything. Ryan, Ryan is like a Swiss clock maker. He knows exactly what he wants.
你知道，身体喜剧有趣，或者我们被允许，你知道，一个在这里的笑话，在。色调衬衫。是的。而他，他只是，你知道，有时就像你有一种感觉，导演不太确定，并且愿意接受一切。瑞安，瑞安就像一个瑞士钟表匠。他确切地知道他想要什么。
He knows what level and tone he wants at exact. I was so impressed by his. I would imagine Wes Anderson is a lot like that too, because there are, there are moments that are heartbreakingly nuanced in, in their, in their drama, in their authenticity, in their humanity, but then there's just these hugely absurd, broad, slapsticky, almost cartoonish comical moments and they all work in the same world. Yeah. I would imagine Edward is, is Wes Anderson more sort of not tonally, tonally specific
他确切地知道他想要什么水平和基调。我对他印象非常深刻。我想象韦斯·安德森也差不多，因为有，有时刻在他们的戏剧、真实性、人性中令人心碎地细致入微，但随后又有一些巨大的荒谬、宽泛、闹剧、几乎卡通化的喜剧时刻，它们都在同一个世界里工作。是的。我想象爱德华是，韦斯·安德森是否更，不是在基调上，在基调上具体
in the sense that he has a, has a, it appears to me that he might be more sort of inclined to have a, have a set idea of tonally exactly how he wants the film to be. He does. He's, I mean, needless to say the production design, the costumes, it's like two within an inch of its life that there's nothing he'll come in and he will step in. And, and, and, and adjust your tie just so, you know, like, like, like, he's like, sorry, the Donné racket, that particular model of Donné racket didn't come out until 78. So you can't have it in this shot.
在某种意义上，他有一个，有一个，在我看来，他可能更倾向于有一个，有一个设定的想法，在基调上确切地想要电影是什么样子。他确实。我是说，不用说，制作设计、服装，它就像离它的生命只有两英寸，没有什么他不会介入的，他会介入，他会介入，他会介入，他会调整你的领带，恰到好处，你知道，就像，就像，他就像，抱歉，唐内球拍，那个特定型号的唐内球拍直到78年才出来。所以你不能在镜头里有它。
It's more, is it the, is it the angle he wants you to hold it at is the, you know, his precision and his, his, his feeling for the, the, the visual aesthetic is legendary. And it's everything everyone would think he is that hands-on and that, that, that precise and he cares an enormous amount about those details. And like a lot of people who are like that, when you're in the moment and he seems to be splitting hairs, you can have a moment where you're so, can we just, Jesus, let's just get on with it. Like, let's get on with it.
更多的是，是他想要你握住它的角度，是，你知道，他的精确度和他，他，他对视觉美学的感受是传奇的。而且每个人都会认为他就是那样，那种亲力亲为，那种，那种精确，他非常关心那些细节。而且像很多那样的人一样，当你在那一刻，他似乎在吹毛求疵时，你可能会有一个时刻，你如此，我们能，天哪，让我们继续吧。就像，让我们继续吧。
Right. It's all great. But then you can't argue with the total effect. Right. Right. You can't argue with the total effect of the final product. And so when we got, it's going back to that thing you were saying earlier, I love working with people like that because when you, when you are a fan going in, when you believe in,
对。这一切都很棒。但你不能反驳整体效果。对。对。你不能反驳最终产品的整体效果。所以当我们得到，回到你刚才说的那件事，我喜欢和那样的人一起工作，因为当你，当你是一个粉丝进去时，当你相信，
when you believe that the final result that they consistently deliver is so good that you just want to be inside whatever that process is, you surrender any defensiveness. You surrender self-protection. You surrender, it liberates you because you're in the hands, you're in trust, you're in the state of trust. Right. And at the end of the day, if Fincher wants to do it 40 times or 50 or whatever, you find the gear within yourself that is saying, well, this is what this is.
当你相信他们始终交付的最终结果是如此之好，以至于你只想进入那个过程的任何部分，你就会放弃任何防御。你放弃自我保护。你放弃，它解放了你，因为你在手中，你在信任中，你在信任的状态中。对。而在一天结束时，如果芬奇想做40次或50次或任何次数，你会在自己内心找到那个齿轮，说，好吧，这就是它。
This is how he does it. And you love it, right? And Wes will give you, I mean, I, you know, you can say, oh, no one would give Edward a line reading. He has line readings all the time, imitating Wes's line readings is a joy. It's a joy to get a line reading from Wes. You know, and, and I mean, you talk about like, I, I, the Tenenbaum's like he, he told me one time that I'm not telling tales out of school.
这就是他做事的方式。而且你喜欢它，对吧？而韦斯会给你，我是说，我，你知道，你可以说，哦，没有人会给爱德华读台词。他一直有台词朗读，模仿韦斯的台词朗读是一种乐趣。从韦斯那里得到台词朗读是一种乐趣。你知道，而且，我是说，你谈论像，我，我，《特南鲍姆一家》就像他，他有一次告诉我，我不是在泄露学校里的故事。
I think Gene Hackman was, was, was legendarily tough on people. Yes. Like Fran, Fran McDormand told me on Mississippi Burning that he was so mean to Willem Dafoe that she called him mean Gene and, and, and, and you know, look, the guys, he's Gene Hackman, like my, my view is like, be any way you want to be, just give us that thing. Right. Right. But, but Willem told me when we were doing Mother's Brooklyn, Willem told me that, that
我想吉恩·哈克曼，是，是传说中对人很严厉。是的。就像弗兰，弗兰·麦克多蒙德在《密西西比在燃烧》中告诉我，他对威廉·达福太刻薄了，以至于她叫他刻薄的吉恩，而且，而且，而且你知道，看，这家伙，他是吉恩·哈克曼，就像我的，我的观点是，你想怎么做就怎么做，只要给我们那个东西。对。对。但，但威廉在我们在做《布鲁克林孤儿》时告诉我，威廉告诉我，
he had been pretty tough on him, but that he was telling himself as a young actor, hey, this guy's a grizzled old FBI agent and he's supposed to be tough on me. I don't, don't, you know, don't fold, like let him lean into it and go with it. But he said the night before his big monologue, like his biggest monologue in Mississippi Burning, he said Hackman took him out to dinner and he said, he thought, oh, wow, you know, finally he's kind of like, you know, you know, things, and he said they were having a drink and not saying anything. He said Hackman, Hackman looked at him, this is like, this is like two weeks from the end
他对他相当严厉，但他当时作为一个年轻演员告诉自己，嘿，这家伙是一个饱经风霜的老FBI探员，他应该对我严厉。我不要，不要，你知道，不要折叠，就像让他靠进去，跟着它走。但他说是他最大的独白的前一天晚上，就像他在《密西西比在燃烧》中最大的独白，他说哈克曼带他出去吃晚饭，他说，他想，哦，哇，你知道，终于他有点像，你知道，你知道，事情，他说他们当时在喝一杯，什么也没说。他说哈克曼，哈克曼看着他，这就像，这就像离结束还有两周
of the, there's a whole shoot and he said, Hackman looked at me and goes, so is this what you're going with? Oh my God. No way. You're going to keep doing this right to the end, huh? But anyway, I thought about that because Wes said, one of my favorite moments in Royal Town and Bumps is when Hackman is in the kitchen with Danny Glover and he says, are you making time with my wife Coltrane?
整个拍摄，他说哈克曼看着我说，所以这就是你要用的？哦，天哪。不可能。你要一直这样做直到最后，对吧？但总之，我想到了这一点，因为韦斯说，我在《特南鲍姆一家》中最喜欢的时刻之一是当哈克曼在厨房里和丹尼·格洛弗在一起时，他说，你在和我妻子科尔特兰调情吗？
And Danny Glover goes, did you just call me Coltrane? You know, and he's like going to get in a fight with him, right? And Wes said that Hackman came in in a good mood saying, this is a funny scene, you know, it's a good scene, Wes. And Wes said, oh, geez, thanks, Gene, you know, and he said, just one thing, I think we should change Coltrane to Satchmo. And Wes said, he goes, oh, well, why, you know, why? And he said, well, you and I know what Coltrane is and it's funny to us, but a lot of people,
而丹尼·格洛弗说，你刚才叫我科尔特兰？你知道，他就像要和他打架，对吧？而韦斯说，哈克曼当时心情很好，说，这是一个有趣的场景，你知道，这是一个好场景，韦斯。而韦斯说，哦，天哪，谢谢，吉恩，你知道，他说，只有一件事，我认为我们应该把科尔特兰改成萨奇莫。而韦斯说，他去，哦，好吧，为什么，你知道，为什么？他说，嗯，你和我都知道科尔特兰是什么，这对我们来说很有趣，但很多人，
that might be a little things. I think more people know what Satchmo means and it's going to be more accessible to more people. And Wes said, well, the thing is, I like the sound of the word Coltrane and I think if some people don't know what that means, I'm okay with that. And he said, Hackman said, it's just our audience, but fuck him, I guess, right? And he's just like in a black and black mood for the rest of the day. And I'm like, you know, whenever people say like, oh, you know, so and so is difficult
那可能有点东西。我认为更多的人知道萨奇莫意味着什么，它对更多的人来说会更容易理解。而韦斯说，嗯，事情是，我喜欢科尔特兰这个词的声音，我认为如果有些人不知道那意味着什么，我没关系。他说，哈克曼说，这只是我们的观众，但去他妈的，我想，对吧？而他就像那天剩下的时间里心情都很糟糕。而我就像，你知道，每当人们说，哦，你知道，某某人很难相处
or whatever, I'm like, I'm like, I just talked about this with Phil Hoffman. I feel like there's like, there's like the serious actors of our generation. And then there's those guys, you know, like they are just a totally, it's a totally different breed. I really honestly think a lot of those guys, I've gotten to work with a lot of them, Harvey Kytel, a couple of times, De Niro, a couple of times, John Voight, you know, Nick Nolte, like you go through, here's these guys, they are, they are in a different frequency entirely. Like it's not the language we grew up in.
或者什么的，我就像，我就像，我刚和菲尔·霍夫曼谈过这个。我觉得有，有我们这一代严肃的演员。然后是那些家伙，你知道，就像他们完全是，这是一个完全不同的品种。我真的老实说认为那些家伙中的很多人，我有幸和他们中的很多人一起工作，哈维·凯特尔，几次，德尼罗，几次，强·沃特，你知道，尼克·诺尔蒂，就像你经历过，这里是这些家伙，他们是，他们是，他们处于一个完全不同的频率。就像这不是我们成长的语言。
They authentically don't give a shit. No. And also, I mean, I don't want to say they're weird, but they just like, like when Phil and I were doing, we did two, we did two movies back to back and we did the 25th hour with Spike Lee, we were working on that. And you know, Phil was himself, like, you know, a curmudgeonly dude sometimes I really loved him, but he, he could be, he could be prickly and stuff. And we were talking and, and he, we were talking about, he'd worked with De Niro and he was
他们真实地不在乎。不。而且，我是说，我不想说他们很奇怪，但他们只是喜欢，就像当菲尔和我正在做，我们连续做了两部电影，我们和斯派克·李一起做了《第25小时》，我们在做那个。而且你知道，菲尔就是他自己，就像，你知道，一个有时脾气暴躁的家伙，我真的很爱他，但他，他可能，他可能很棘手等等。我们当时在谈论，而且，他，我们在谈论，他曾和德尼罗一起工作，他当时
like, does it make you, don't you just feel like a square with these guys? And for Phil, for Phil to say anyone makes him feel like a square, like it, it's just, there's just something different about those guys and the way they work and how weird they can be. They're, they're so not, some of them are just not. They're kind of like not of us. No.
就像，这让你，你不觉得和这些家伙在一起像个方块吗？而对于菲尔，对于菲尔来说，说任何人让他觉得像个方块，就像它，它只是，这些家伙和他们做事的方式以及他们能有多奇怪，确实有些不同。他们，他们太不，他们中的一些人只是不。他们有点像不是我们的人。不。
Yeah. Yeah. What's your, what, what, what are you, what are you, you're so great at, at, at so many things clearly as we've covered here. What would people be surprised at that you're terrible at? What, what, what do you do that? Like I, I can't dance or I can't, I don't even sing in the shower. I wish I, I have no facility for, for drawing.
是的。是的。什么是你的，什么，什么，你，你如此擅长，在，在，在这么多事情上，显然正如我们在这里所涵盖的。人们会惊讶于你什么做得非常糟糕？什么，什么，你做什么，就像我，我不会跳舞，或者我不会，我甚至不在淋浴时唱歌。我希望我，我没有绘画的天赋。
I've always wanted, you know, like when I draw storyboards, it's just, it's the, it's the most embarrassing thing in the world. They're useless. You can't draw depth, right? I finally ended up with these apps. I figured out that if I wanted to go around in New York and, and storyboard a car chase or something like that, I would take, I would take pictures of all the angles and then in my childish scrawl, like try to draw the shape of a car in a general arrow direction
我一直想要，你知道，就像当我画故事板时，它只是，它是世界上最尴尬的事情。它们没用。你画不出深度，对吧？我最终用这些应用程序结束了。我发现如果我想在纽约四处走动，并为汽车追逐或其他类似的事情画故事板，我会拍下所有角度的照片，然后在我的幼稚涂鸦中，就像尝试画出汽车的形状，朝着一般的箭头方向
on it. And it's like, I'm so envious, I'm so envious of people who can, like I would draw a box with a circle next to it and say, that's a car. And then draw an arrow and be unable to have the arrow stay on the line of the street. What about the opposite? What would people be really amazed that you're fantastic at? Mmm, amazed that I'm good at. Yeah.
在上面。而且就像，我太羡慕了，我太羡慕那些能，就像我会画一个盒子，旁边有一个圆圈，说，那是一辆车。然后画一个箭头，却无法让箭头停在街道的线上。那相反的情况呢？人们会真正惊讶于你非常擅长什么？嗯，惊讶于我擅长什么。是的。
Like, are you musical at all? You're playing anything? Yeah, but I'm not amazing. I've been a pilot for a long time. Oh, wow. I'm a pretty good pilot. That qualifies. I think I knew that.
比如，你懂音乐吗？你玩什么吗？是的，但我并不精通。我当飞行员已经很长时间了。哦，哇。我是一个相当不错的飞行员。这有资格。我想我知道这一点。
I love surfings like my later in life addiction and it's something I'm, like I'm okay at now, but I really wish I was better. You know, if there, if there's a thing that I, that like haunts my dreams that I really wish I was, that I'm trying to get better at and that I love like in an addictive way, I don't want to. That's not that great thing where you, when you and Pitt did Fight Club forever, people when they think about you without your shirt on, they think of you as super ripped. So you kind of get to, that kind of lives forever, that image.
我热爱冲浪，就像我晚年才有的瘾一样，我现在冲浪水平还行，但我真的很希望自己能更好。你知道，如果有什么东西一直萦绕在我的梦里，让我真的很想变得更好，而且让我像上瘾一样热爱，我不想这样。当你和皮特拍《搏击俱乐部》时，那并不是什么了不起的事，人们想到你没穿上衣的样子时，会觉得你身材超级棒。所以那种形象会永远留存。
And it's something. You understand that Brad is Brad and I'm me, right? No. Like you. Jason's crying right now. Jason is just thinking about it. I will never be stuck with that reputation. How much less do I have to eat?
这很特别。你明白布拉德是布拉德，我是我，对吧？不。就像你。杰森现在都快哭了。杰森只是在想这件事。我永远不会被那种名声所困扰。我得少吃多少东西啊？
I'm going to say something that's, that's not correct because the first time we met, the first time we really hung out, we went to dinner, took your shirts off on Sunset Boulevard and you were in the middle of doing, you were the first person I knew who did the clean diet. Do you remember? Oh my God, that is going back. You, you, you and Amanda had done the clean diet and you'd been on it for like a while and we walked in and you walked up to the table and I went, oh my God, this guy is chiseled
我要说一件不准确的事，因为我们第一次见面，第一次真正聚在一起时，我们去吃晚餐，你在日落大道上脱掉了衬衫，你当时正在做，你是我认识的第一个做“纯净饮食”的人。你还记得吗？天哪，那都过去多久了。你和阿曼达当时在做纯净饮食，已经坚持了一段时间，我们走进去，你走到桌边，我说，天哪，这家伙线条太分明了。
and he looks chiseled and he looks like he has the body of a college athlete. And I was like, Jason Bateman, is that fit? Well, now he's chiseled, but he has the, he has the body of like an old man who's in hospice. Right. Like a veal. And because if you do it too long. It all becomes porridge.
他看起来线条分明，有着大学运动员的身体。我当时想，杰森·贝特曼，身材这么好吗？好吧，现在他线条分明，但他有着像住在临终关怀医院的老人的身体。对吧。就像小牛肉。因为如果你做得太久了。一切都会变成粥。
Right. Because he's been on that very, you know, he's been on a version of that diet for 20 years now. Yeah. Just keeping myself in pleasure. Yeah. Yeah. But that was at the start.
对。因为他已经坚持那种饮食方式，你知道，他已经坚持了20年了。是的。只是为了让自己保持愉悦。是的。是的。但那是在开始的时候。
It's because I've got an enormous man inside of me waiting to get out. You know, I just have to keep my eye on the ball. I'm just saying I was actually impressed by your, um, thank you. Well, there you go. You should see me now. I had an enormous man inside of me and I was okay with it for a while. So listen, there's you. Sean is ending.
那是因为我内心住着一个巨大的男人，等着出来。你知道，我只是必须专注于目标。我只是说我其实对你的……印象深刻，谢谢。好吧，就是这样。你应该看看现在的我。我内心住着一个巨大的男人，有一段时间我还能接受。所以听着，那是你。肖恩要结束了。
You know the beautiful. I'm just saying. That's how we're going to end it. That's how we're going to end it. No, it's been delightful. No, it is. Do you have anything guys? It's been delightful.
你知道那很美。我只是说。我们就要这样结束了。我们就要这样结束了。不，这很愉快。不，确实是。你们有什么要说的吗？这很愉快。
What a delight to talk to you after all these years. Questions about every single movie you've been in, but I know, let's just go have dinner. Dinner. Four of us will go eat. Yeah, we should know. And, uh, thank you for spending all this time with us. Please. Yeah.
这么多年后能和你聊天真是太愉快了。关于你演过的每一部电影都有问题，但我知道，我们去吃晚餐吧。晚餐。我们四个人去吃。是的，我们应该知道。而且，谢谢你花这么多时间陪我们。不客气。是的。
It was a delight. Thanks for having me. Absolutely. Great to meet you. Catch you guys soon. All right, Edward. See you, pal. Thanks, bud.
这很愉快。谢谢你们邀请我。当然。很高兴见到你们。回头见。好的，爱德华。再见，伙计。谢谢，哥们。
Bye. Oh man. That was, uh, what a, what a thoughtful, pleasant, normal, incredibly talented man. Yeah. He brings a lot. There's a lot going on, Jay, that, that you knew, like the, I didn't know the philanthropy and the investment and the, oh, I'm surprised that you didn't ask him how much. I'm surprised he didn't say, give me a number because usually you'd go, give me a number.
再见。天哪。那真是……多么体贴、愉快、正常、才华横溢的人啊。是的。他带来了很多东西。杰，有很多事情你不知道，比如慈善事业和投资，哦，我很惊讶你没问他赚了多少。我很惊讶你没说，给我个数字，因为通常你会说，给我个数字。
How much you got? How much you got? How much you got? How much you got? If we did have dinner together, Sean would probably open with that. Would you? Absolutely. And while we're still looking at the menu, because you're looking at prices, how much
你有多少？你有多少？你有多少？你有多少？如果我们真的在一起吃晚餐，肖恩可能会以此开场。你会吗？当然。当我们还在看菜单时，因为你在看价格，多少
you make off of Uber? What's going on? How much did you make? How much? Give me the number. By the way, it's what everybody wants to know. You know who else has been real savvy with all that stuff is Ashton Kutcher. Yes.
你从优步赚了多少？怎么回事？你赚了多少？多少？给我个数字。顺便说一句，这是每个人都想知道的。你知道还有谁在这些方面很精明吗？阿什顿·库彻。是的。
Super savvy. And Gio Ciri. Thanks for the breaking news. Oh, that one I knew. That one I knew. That's well known. No, that one I know. I didn't know about.
超级精明。还有吉奥·西里。谢谢你的突发新闻。哦，那个我知道。那个我知道。那是众所周知的。不，那个我知道。我不知道关于……
I see him. I didn't know about Edward either. Yeah. No, these guys, they've got their finger on the pulse. By the way, and all his stories, he's, I love how he'll open it is about the stories about each job and like the actors, they're so, those are so funny. Right. Yeah.
我看到了。我也不知道爱德华的事。是的。不，这些家伙，他们对脉搏了如指掌。顺便说一句，他所有的故事，我喜欢他如何开启关于每份工作的故事，比如演员，它们太……那些太有趣了。对吧。是的。
So funny. So many of the people that he's worked with, just, yeah, stunning. And maybe we could all have dinner and will you could invite your Canadian friend that they're, that your friends with, what's his name? Mike. Bye. Bye. Beautiful.
太有趣了。他合作过的那么多人，真的，太棒了。也许我们都可以一起吃晚餐，你可以邀请你那位加拿大朋友，就是你朋友的那位，他叫什么名字？迈克。再见。再见。美丽。
Beautiful. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart.
美丽。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。
Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjalf, and Bennett Barbicó. Smart.
是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。《Smartless》是由迈克尔·格兰特·特里、罗伯·阿姆贾尔夫和贝内特·巴比科100%有机且手工制作的。聪明。
Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart. Yes. Smart.
是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。是的。聪明。
Yes. Smart. Yes. You There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的。聪明。是的。你。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。